[Musique]
faux
voilà le micromarché pas désolé c'était
c'était sur but jusqu'à me vois plein de
gens qui fassent jouait déjà de trois
personnes qui demandent ce qui se passe
on va avoir le match d'ici à une petite
dizaine de minutes donc j'étais censé
prendre l'antenne dix minutes avant mai
mais comme comme j'aurais fait les gens
se demander ce qui se passe et voilà je
décide de prendre un peu en avance donc
je vais éteindre mon téléphone en même
temps ça va être fait il faut que je
bloque voilà ça c'est bon comme ça ça
c'est fait salut à efficience 31 salut à
julos tard salut à jojo salua you can't
matem vous salue le grand gourou
donc on va suivre ce match dingli rennes
donc contre nez peau et demain 18 heures
on aura pour nous enfin le grand choc
qui sera mvl contre sow donc j'ai envie
de dire pour nous français évidemment le
match le plus intéressant sera demain on
va quand même se suivre ça à la cool
hein puisque milieu d'après midi 16
heures début du match ça va durer
jusqu'à 20h on a le temps on s'installe
tranquille on arrête de bosser si on
peut on se fait un petit et un petit
café on se prend les pop corn hot chips
une bière sans alcool et on se lance un
prono devant le bouton de nice et ben je
dirais dingli rennes mais coûte même si
même si pas y avoir un championnat du
monde de 2,2 de quoi puzzle battle world
championship et surveillons de peu de
puzzle run truc auquel je vais pas
participer salua km 31 salut charpentier
bon après c'est plus demain si si vous
avez un match à choisir entre celui
d'aujourd'hui et de demain
j'ai envie de dire favoriser celui de
demain il y aura maxime la bon c'est un
signe de la fiche mais après j'ai envie
de dire comparé à la fiche de demain
évidemment on va on va préférer celle de
demain
j'ai envie de faire profiter solide
demain si vous pouvez faire les deux
fait les deux si vous pouvez n'en faire
qu'un fait celui de demain au japon
n'est pas très nombreux pour le moment
mais ça risque d'arriver petit à petit
tout cas j'espère la presse avec
l'horaire est pas est pas évident mais
petit à petit ça devrait arriver donc
donc donc qu'est ce que je peux vous
raconter je sais pas que vous racontez
je ne sais pas je sors de ma grotte
mvele aux candidats de 1000 ventes pas
encore sûr va loin d'être sûr en fait
d'ailleurs loin d'être sûre du lautard
j'ai même envie de dire de moins en
moins sûr salut asie nous 21000 salut
tonton bonjour à toi est-ce qu'on peut
changer son pseudo switch écoute là tu
me pose une colle jean sérien efficience
31 pourquoi tu voulais mettre quoi
efficience 30,2 par le service est un
vecteur des grilles tiouka embourbé à
écouter pas grand chose ça bravo grille
tout face à un copain
les grands joueurs dans les grands
moments gagne voilà ce sera ce tout ce
que j'ai à dire cette victoire j'ai
envie de dire on sait gré tout cas un
grand joueur grand moment grands matches
très importants il n'y pas de bluff
mon cas mais n'est pas un grand joueur
bah pas encore non c'est un très bon
joueur mais c'est pas un grand joueur
faudra fu chi pour entrer dans le
panthéon des grands joueurs faut faire
quand même des gros frais d'armes
bon après tout c'est qu'il n'a jamais
gagnée les candidats donc est ce que
vraiment un grand joueur mais quand même
dans les moments importants on sent que
qu'il est au dessus mais mvl tout ce
qu'on lui souhaite c'est il a le niveau
pour le faire c'est de cette gagner
c'est au moins d'aller aux candidats
déjà ce qui est quand même quelque chose
qui manque largement à sa carrière
donc déjà d'aller aux candidats et puis
d'être un peu menaçants au candidat
c'est quand même ce qui lui manque pour
passer dans une autre dans une autre
dimension pour lancer vraiment un très
très beau joueur mais il lui manque un
petit peu ce le fait d'avoir approché ou
menacés en tout cas de participer à une
finale de championnat du monde
c'est ce qui lui manque encore donc on
lui souhaite
on lui souhaite d'aller se guérit tout
comme triple champion du monde de blitz
même si vous allez me dire oui mais
championnat du monde de blitz tanina
dana mais il a quand même gagné des
tournois où il y avait tout le monde
donc il ya quand même ce truc de kim en
tout cas maxime encore pour pour monter
dans une autre dimension
dalé d'aller chercher d'aller chercher
mieux j'ai envie de dire d'aller
chercher mieux est d'aller chercher un
petit ou un grand titre ou un ou en tout
cas des candidats
du coup on change chercher quand même
les candidats et en faisant un tournoi
intéressant aux candidats ils
changeraient un petit peu de dimension
ça me semble être quelque chose
d'important pour maxime icart haut et
fort en bits soit est bien sûr très fort
mais il n'a jamais été champion du monde
donc c'est quand même pas quand même un
titre de champion du monde même si sa
hambli dessous quoi ça change quand même
beaucoup de choses me semble-t-il c'est
quand même un truc qui fait la
différence à un moment donné d'avoir eu
un titre des gros titres comme ça les
candidats c'est aussi quelque chose
d'important
ok c'est quand même des choses des
choses importantes donc maxime c'est
vrai qu'on espère de tout notre coeur
qui se qualifie pour pour un petit peu
rentrer dans une autre catégorie j'ai
envie de dire pour entrer dans une
catégorie supérieure et donc voir robert
et on voit une tête de robert s en fait
le speech est ce qui va se lancer nos
amis américains qui montre le tableau
non non je vais pas je vais pas le voir
comme ça y'a que si je fais ça
mais ça m'a remis la musique mais bon
c'est bon du coup on le voit donc mal
tableau avec artemiev qui s'est donc
qualifié pour les demies qui jouera le
vainqueur du match sow maxime qu'on
suivra demain
et là on regarde la partie de tableau de
gauche avec king lear et de dépôt qui
joueront le vainqueur d'un match
intéressante que qui se jouera je crois
le 4 décembre la date a été fixée entre
hikaru nakamura et duda un match qui
sera peut-être pas si simple et donc on
va suivre 90 minutes de 5 + 1 une heure
de 3 + 1 et 30 minutes de bullet salua
tamouls bull et demain sera à 18 heures
à ne pas rater un sou en aucun prétexte
c'est bien dans quel but et sing sing
élimination au cas où toi donc si tu
perds tu as perdu
en gros sur winner of match à 2,26 tous
de nex line the bracket
le vainqueur de chaque match bas se
qualifient
j'ai envie de te dire c'est un peu des
infos etc au plus cinq ans même si tu
perds tu éliminé su gagner qualifié bon
l'inversé aurait été étonnant après qui
sait mais ça va quand même été un petit
peu étonnant si le vainqueur du match
était éliminé le perdant qualifié bon pé
d'information c'est un peu comme les
notices d'aider des machines à laver des
machines à les trucs comme ça ne m'était
pas votre chat bon pourquoi pas si plus
tu es mouillé c'est ça le feu ça brûle
ouais mais c'est ce niveau d'information
donc l'envoi un petit peu le les têtes
des joueurs j'aime dingli rennes 27 ans
chinois de 1800 en classique de 1832 en
rapide 2867 en blitz numéro 3 à 3 et 2
mondial se donne chef house et on voit
que son élan beat c'était quand même
moindre sur internet par rapport à celui
de l'epo numéro 6 en classique
alors là j'imagine que c'est au moment
où ils ont fait le ils ont pris les les
joueurs numéro 12 ans rapide et numéro
trois en blitz prédictions de
l'ordinateur comme une victoire de dépôt
15 13 mais ça va plus se jouer à mon
avis parce que c'est sur internet sur un
vrai chic y est je pense que ding est
plus fort mais il a peut-être moins
l'habitude des échelons en 2d mais moi
je vais quand même digne favori salut
rojo
j'ai eu prétexte serait heures du mat
ici même en dormir même si même été
commentaires des cochons de l'été ou du
coup cochonou j'ai oublié déjà sous ses
vêtements tu es venu voilà donc on va
lancer le match on voit un dépôt qui ce
cadre dingli rennes qui fera toujours la
même tête pendant tout le match ça on le
sait au moins on est au courant et on va
suivre brasse m côté ding si on le peut
pour se mettre du côté du joueur chômage
serait plutôt pour le joueur chinois du
goût pour un peu changé et écouter
j'aime bien avoir un peu de nouvelles
têtes des nouveaux résultats
winamax neumann qui regroupe des jeunes
du rsa dans les années 20 tu sais où je
peux trouver l'info non pas vraiment
alors est-ce que c'est parti voilà ça y
est c'est parti
observez la partie on peut le faire
alors on a raté juste et quelques
secondes de 4,5 à fraguer saisissent
espagnol as his nanani nanana et tourer
b5 loubet trois des six donc ça se
développe alors il va jouer problème ces
trois puits pour jouer avec des quatre
voilà c'est chose faite
fu g4 il vient clouer le cavalier et met
la pression sur le centre fouet trois
hommes sur qui est provocatrice y de
mémoire il ya fou des cinq qui fait une
petite double attaque désagréable donc
il prend une fois en des quatre
cavaliers à saint qui s'en prend aux
fous le footsie reculons pour à jaillir
en c4 pour s'en prendre aux fous et 3 et
aux pions b2
le fou le 3 qui repart en c1 c'est pas
une mauvaise case dans l'est dans
l'espagnol c5 met la pression sur le
centre et en cas de poussée on pourrait
éventuellement revenir vers 5 pour
mettre la pression sur le cavalier f3
améliorer cavani d2 qui tient tout donc
des cinq possibles est-ce que décès
seraient aussi possibles pour échanger
échanger faire re 5 je crois pas ça à
l'air d'être pourri e5 est ce que c'est
une option et je sais pas mais il a fait
des cinq le premier coup qui venait à
l'idée puisque sur cavaliers 5 pour
jouer sur le clouage ya cavaliers b d2
qui défend cavale et 17 alors ils
préparent à l'arrivée du camion e5
éventuellement des coups comme f5 pour
venir casser centre et jouer la tour h3
en chasse le fou alors est-ce que sur
france 5 il veut g4 j'ai envie de dire
peut-être je lâche pas d'infos je ne
lâche pas d'infos d'un autre côté fou
prend f3 et cavaliers e5 ça semble être
aussi une option
à noter qu'on peut aussi faire fou prend
ff6 pour venir jouer sur le pion b2 les
blancs qui joue cavalier c3 qui couvrent
leurs pions on peut jouer un coup comme
des quatre maintenant s'en prendre aux
cavaliers lecavalier qui recule les
cavaliers des uns est maintenant peu
être à 5 à 4 pour venir un peu porté sur
non via cavalia cinq possibles mais
caveau cavalli b6 et à tours 8
la position me semble intéressante pour
les noirs personnellement j'aime bien
les noirs écoutez je sais pas ce que
vous en pensez mais et noir me semble
avoir une position tout à fait correct
donc les u15 dame de excusez moi je
vérifier que tout soit bien en place
dans la technique cavaliers b6 du coup
est fou detroit alors maintenant est-ce
que cavalier ou 5 avec l'idée c4 pour
être une idée il fait 1 4 il menace
peut-être à 3 la tour qui vient en b1
donc il prépare peut-être b3 pour
colmater
ici on vous paie 3 par nous mêmes il y
aura cavaliers ces trois noms qui vient
faire cavalier ou 5
il veut éventuellement c4 et b3 alors
sur f4 ckt peut-être c'était être une
option aussi mais il a joué cavalier e3
donc ils empêchent ces quatre il prend
une fois sur tours c'est 8 tu auras
cavaliers c4 il viendra à colmater le
trou il peut jouer peut-être un coup
comme dams et 8 avec l'idée sur
cavaliers c4 de fer damas six et de
jouer peut-être un clouage avoir
apprécié b3 est possible mais ça
semblait intéressant dams et 8 il a fait
dame 17 alors il vient contrôler une
galaxie de cases d'accord kg cas donc
ces quatre épreuves 6 le fou qui lie en
d4 fouet trois c4 toujours pas possible
parce que ray dame prend des quatre f5
et peut-être une option haifa ch 5
encore plus fort la même idée de jouer
sur ce cavalier qui a plus trop de cases
à l'espionnage construit une seule peut
pendant vingt minutes durant le stream
le micro marche rassurez moi
alors on nous dit mais je me demande
comment ndinga peut-être aussi pour
ampli de sans jamais jouer sur internet
irl doit pas forcément avoir l'occasion
de blitz et tous les jours je te rassure
il a battu magnus un an rapide dans le
dans les départage de line of men 2 de
l'asim que phil cup et je te rassure
c'est un excellent bitzer dingli rennes
seulement là tu vois il a une connexion
à une barre donc il ya une très mauvaise
connexion ce qui est quand même un vrai
problème
et en plus il joue rarement sur internet
donc mauvaise connexion et mauvaises
habitudes ça t'enlève bien 50 points de
puissance quoi mais bon il est peut-être
tellement au dessus que qui peut quand
même faire quelque chose dont tour à
deux et peut-être sa connexion va papa
va pas sombrer 1
comment il s'entraîne des tris blitz
avec d'autres chinois gens ce à quoi
tient une nouvelle épreuve inscrite dans
sa salle de bain avec un vieux ventilo
derrière ça c'est une vraie question
mais il a vraiment l'air d'être dans sa
salle de bain au dessus de sa tête et un
truc en bois c'est vrai qu'on a vraiment
l'impression qu'il en les chiottes quoi
vous pensez qu'ils jouent sur le trône
vous pensez qu'ils jouent assis sur le
trône
non quand même pas ce serait beau quoi
aîné paul ney peau ses rideaux sont un
peu dégueu dans mon cas mille fois en c3
la tour là attention tu as 5 qui peut
être un peu faible un jour la pousse de
5 qui peut arriver d'un autre côté la
torah de et bien ces cas très difficile
à percer mais il le fait quand même
alors sur pions prouesse qui veut faire
cavalier à quatre cavaliers c5 et venir
retouches et ça ce serait vraiment bien
joué ainsi son idée ses cavaliers à
quatre ce serait vraiment intéressant
après peut-être aussi des quake arena à
4 kg 5 et est là et la dame peut pas
rester au contact
c'est joli ce qui est en train de faire
diminuer la petite manoeuvre le jeu dans
le petit périmètre mais il peut pas
prendre le pion et enfin le plomb est
assez protégé est ce que la dame peut
venir au f5 pour gagner un tempo sur le
fou mais y aurait des preuves qui
réattaque rella touré et créerait une
jolie protection dont il a pris en 5 et
sur cavaliers prends je pense bien qu'il
veut dame f5 où il peut vouloir damev
cinq en tout cas et surtout prend
peut-être fou prend et la dame qui
arriveront à f/5 plus tard ou d'un même
et je sais pas j'ai l'impression que
c'est un f5 ça peut être pénible parce
que sur fou prend cavaliers prendre un
f5 sa connecte sur f2 aussi il faut pas
l'oublier c'est hyper intéressant ce
qu'a fait le joueur chinois
c'est hyper intéressant et la dame bref
5 qui arrive direct alors sur foot
france et 3 il veut peut-être prendre 3
prendre 3 et reprendre en c3 avec l'idée
de pousser ses deux amphores c'est
intéressant parce qu'il a donné un pion
le chinois mais il a le cavalier qui
fait office de deux tours de contrôle
ouais c'est vraiment intéressant ce qui
ce qui joue holding en tout cas je
trouve ça assez originale de la part du
chinois est fou des quatre joué par
assez intéressant ce site ou reprendre
trois fous prendre trois jouées par un
dépôt pour replacer le fou pour couvrir
et pour laisser le pion en b 4 mais
voyez ce cavalier là qui empêche un peu
tout mais y'a le fou qui l'attaquent
attention alors ouais ce qui va partir
ce cavalier 6 par an le cas tout en d3
le problème c'est que le pion des pourra
filer et ce à un dangereux criminel
c'est un politicien il peut très vite
arriver on des huit attention attention
le criminel de données pommier achi qui
semble être plus difficile à arrêter que
le criminel de ding sari criminels qui
est quand même bien bien tenus en
respect par la tour parce que des six
peut y aller ouais là le dangereux
criminel est parti mais le cavalier qui
bloque un peu la colonne 17 et pas
forcément encore une menace mais ça
pourrait le devenir très rapidement
attention peut-être g5 ici jouable pour
envoyer g4 toujours intéressant d'être
le premier à jouer j'ai quatre dans une
partie il fait frais phcie s'occupe du
criminel et peut-être veut-il un jour du
cavalier b2 ou quoi mais il me semble
que le pion des six soit vraiment fort
après vingt ans sur ces 5 on peut
prendre prendre prendre et 17 on pourra
venir couvrir fou des cats attention et
afu prend cavaliers pro yakyû f2 en
l'air il fait 17 alors sur dame prend 17
il a bien prévu un truc peut-être
camaïeu 1 mais y aurait cavalier e 5 à
ypres en bécane est sur toi il va
revenir avec tourbe et apparemment donc
dams f5 sur le retour et ding qui veut
peut être préparé un tour un peu plus
méchant avec tours bien qu'ils avalent
et prend un f2 pour s'en prendre à ce
mec là on va voir
alors comment ça va évoluer cette
histoire la tour 1 qui peut qu'il peut
être une vraie menace les pots qui m'a
l'air de prendre beaucoup de temps au
tour de 8,3 à cette aide doit les dignes
watch est la plus vite que ça il a quand
même me 0,9 pour le jouet est tombé 5 il
s'en prend à la dame notre ami nepos
urdin prend b5 fillon prend toi dame
prend il ya le pion b qui va filer donc
la dame qui vient à eux quatre le pion
h5 et en l'air et cavaliers d2 alors
est-ce que la davar parts tir et norbert
geass elle peut il peut faire d'un
proche 5 même peut-être sur échec pour
prendre tout reprend le roi qui monte
mais maintenant ça fait quoi ça fait
deux pions de plus pour le joueur russe
à tour qui vient en d5 le joueur russe
qui est impérial et ça va faire un point
zéro pour tourner post histoire là je
vois pas comment je vois pas comment
notre ami notre ami chinois pourrait
s'en sortir
j'ai envie de dire les nems sont dans le
sac pour les peaux il va pouvoir manger
très sain mais attention quand même deux
pas il ya deux pions de plus il doit
considérer que après qu'un problème si
ça gagne face il va quand même falloir
faire attention à tout en c2 est bien
placé mais peut-être du petit roy un
rouage de roy g3 même pas ils
s'approchent
il va pouvoir aller chercher
c'est tf6 attention de pas faire
pourquoi m6 et les maths en a mais le
roi qui va reculer à lyon va revenir en
trois ou même en g3 attention en rage 2
à tanger de tous rêvent de bien jouer
n'est pas éprouver la paperie g2o coude
avant pour il est tombé toute façon je
sais pas si rouages et 3 il pouvait pas
faire moins que trois plus tôt je sais
pas comment ça se faisait donc
c'est génial il y avait l'envié des
chaussures sur les entraîneurs et c'est
pourquoi donc on a maintenant une anti
grünfeld alors pourquoi en tigre une fed
parce que sur j'ai six cavaliers ces
trois des cinq c'est la green fait déjà
parler plein de fois et donc f3 c'est
une manière de menacer le 4 et de m
une structure de type sami ch et donc là
ouais c'est une manière de jouer un peu
moderne avec g 6e 6 contre les anti
grünfeld où tu acceptes tu te crées des
gruyères mais parce qu'il ya un gruyère
de l'autre côté aussi donc position une
nouvelle fois très intéressante avec des
pièces mal placé des deux côtés même
très mal placé mais j'ai l'impression
qu'il ya plus de lyon dans la position
noir
j'imagine un fou arrivant à 6 le tenir
en j'essaie de jouer des 5 rocks
c'est quelque chose qui me paraît plus
sain à jouer côté noir je sais pas ce
que vous en pensez dans le chat pendant
deux côtés pensez vous en sépare avez
vous un avis dans le tchat
on ne sait pas le châtain pas d'avis
vous pouvez qu'à tous les 7 4 il réussit
mais s'il est noir réussissent à faire
des cinq dans le tempo même apprécié de
4 m et vocale et f4 ça va être dur quand
même la question c'est ce qu'on va
pouvoir faire des cinq dans le tempo
même peut-être au prix d'un pion pour
tout ouvrir et jouer sur sur des pièces
placées de manière un petit peu étrange
pied bat ses rangs la question de la
position pour moi
that is the question tout plaide hifive
or not to play dif arrive comme comme la
vie comme l'a dit un certain shakespeare
dans sa pièce jesse lots donc cinq
arrêts ie8
mais là maintenant peut-être du thé si
ce qui va arriver où f6 ouais je sens
plus de lyon côté noir b4y à avancer les
pions partout où il va se faire contrer
makine phone est exactement mais bon
d'un autre côté il a pris beaucoup d
espace là quand même
donc un ep 8 il veut faire cavalier c6
et retaper sur cinq
bon
vous étroits que va laisser 6 et je me
demande comment fait à l'encan il défend
à il veut jouer sur le clouage et
surtout bessette va peut-être carrément
allaient le bouffer ce truc est ce que
je me demande toujours si on peut
sacrifier quelque chose ici avec les
noirs dams et 7 alors il veut maintenant
fou prend 1,5 vous prend 1,5 et âme
prend 1,5
c'est vrai que tu vas commencer aussi
avisé ses 4 c'est un peu le truc de
lover lover extend quoi de prendre trop
d espace donc il prend hélas les deux
options sont possibles d'apprendre pions
prend puis on prend ça pourrait être
intéressant aussi mesdames fin les deux
sont possibles que dame prend tu
attaques amc-4 tu as devant le prendre
20 m
prenons la position est excellente pour
pour les peaux des six mrc j'attends les
1150 grâce à toi et un peu hagarde
m'attends aussi à lancer pour ça que
c'est pas encore 1600 dommage
5 ouais c'est bien joué ça ils échangent
pas des fous et il va faire fou prend h
trois intermédiaires cavaliers prend des
six dingli rennes qui va se retrouver à
sa 2 0 à cavaliers des cinq
intermédiaire menace cavaliers au 7 mai
monde anne decis gens me dire balech et
il va y avoir foule prend et tour ses
huit froid je crois il va y passer
puis on prend un tour c'est 8 la
structure est dégueu
ouais
kireev 6 d'accord mais il faut commencer
par cavalier apsys fer qui les problèmes
6 dame prend m6 et il va jouer la
structure by égalité matérielle sauf que
pas juste pour montrer un jour tu fait
aveu si cette attaque n'a hélas les
pions sont dégueulasses un toit un tour
f18
il va mettre le tout rend des huit ouais
ok il va essayer de défendre bon an mal
an quitte à faire céder mettre ses pions
sur blanc l'orangé deux pour créer un
peu de liant et c'est défendre ça faut
pas qu'ils se prennent à eux quatre
quand même parce qu'un coup comme 4 est
vite arrivée genre pions prend le cadre
déjà ça tue donc dame prend force est
hélas peut-être un dame f6 pour préparer
tour des huit dames f5 de taquiner à
truffes il ya du dam g5 aussi qui rôdent
situer la dame nature a dû être 5 4
ouais ça m'a l'air d'être quand même
compliqué
dans ces huit maintenant je suis
d'accord à la ghana tor s'est pas
vraiment de l'analyse de partie où il
faut le prendre pour ce que c'est c'est
bien dans son style 1 après c'est plus
[Musique]
c'est plus du ouais c'est plus du résume
ouais je résumais en quelque sorte way
et d'un messi serait bon va réussir à ta
p h3 mais il va récupérer 1,5 mais il va
perdre f3
on va voir
vraiment le seul truc que j'aime pas
trop dans les vidéo d'arcade matters
pour être complètement sincère avec vous
c'est que souvent les analyse c'est que
des variantes d'ordinateur pas comprises
et quelque part je préférerais avoir des
analystes si c'est aussi rapide un truc
plus humain quoi mais plus d'explication
rationnelle de ce qui s'est passé
plus que des plus que des variantes
d'ordi pas trop comprise mais après
c'est un goût personnel de chacun ses
goûts pour ça que je préfère la chaîne
par exemple dans le même style de
danielle king dont café tour des 1 et la
n ya pas un f5 là qui rôdent f54 genre
puisqu'elle 5 va où
suivant des trois il ya eu 4 qui fait
mal si tu veux en 3 et peut-être x 6 x
f4 battu à tête en e2 comme ça tu
protèges tout j'ai pas vraiment compris
dames 6
non mais après c'est le seul truc c'est
pour ça que vous entendez souvent les
bons joueurs qui disent à gad mahtour
nanani nanana ce parce que souvent c'est
vraiment de l'éval de l'ordi en fait
c'est vraiment les blancs sont mieux il
sait pas trop pourquoi il dit parce que
l'ordi enfin en fait si tu le dis pas
comme ça mais c'est juste l'ordi qui dit
qu'ils sont mieux en fait il sait pas
pourquoi ça m'est déjà arrivé de
regarder des vidéos un peu dans l'esprit
de parti j'avais déjà fait pour voir du
comme j'avais analysé les parties est ok
souvent tu sens que les variantes au
moment où elle s'arrête pas parfois
c'est même déjà arrivé de pousser encore
là et les voir que l'ordi avait tort
mais enfin je vis va pas chercher à
comprendre en fait fin il peut pas
comprendre en fait
mais daniel king c'est un peu dans le
même style ce qui fait sauf qu'il est
plus fort aux échecs mais c'est moins
populaire du coup donc en quelque sorte
agathe matin c'est vrai qu'il ya cette
recette de faire de faire rire un genre
de résumer ou ce qu'il dit c'est pas y
comprends pas vraiment pourquoi mais
d'un autre côté les gens qui regardent
non plus donc bon c'est non c'est pas
mal en fait
donc il prend ses six d'accord et le f 5
3 et 7 3 aux 6 m étais tu va la défendre
il a quoi il a deux pions - mais le roi
s'approche pas silhouette arrivants
dessins que ce serait bon et maintenant
il va vouloir tourbe et un tour bessette
voilà c'est sa rentrée sur la colonne
peut-être même tour b6 dans certains cas
même et problème c'est qui va perdre à
la souris taquet s'il est pas capable de
faire flouer f2 en moins de 5 secondes
il ya un problème
ballotté mais tu peux rien faire en fait
si t'es pas capable de jouer des coups
comme francs le plus vite tu peux rien
faire et à la position est dur à jouer
tout mais je comprends que hyper une
seconde partie une seconde par là il va
retomber comme une merde
dans ce sens il est moins bien qu est ce
pas mal surtout prend 1,5 à peine tout
revin et sinon il ya tourcoing f4 et il
a magouillé mais il va perdre autant
j'ai peur a super bien joué menaces tout
reprend ses cinquièmes de magnifiques de
la part de données peau
le fou prend ses cinq pour jouer avec
les deux pions passé lié à la fin et
après f3 tu peux pas empêcher tout
reprend ses cinquièmes de ces
magnifiques 2 0 est non mais oui bon
pour le moment après on sait jamais il
ya déjà des matchs qui sont retournés où
j'ai pas vraiment bien pronostiqué
non c'est bien je n'ai pas qui me paraît
un peu au dessus est donc on rejoue la
même chose que dans la première
qu'est qui va revenir ans et carys
l'arrêté pas mal anding position des
blancs n'étaient pas dans l'est mais il
est déconnecté les machins mais c'est
toujours chez pied pas pour vous en tant
que spectateur mais pour moi en tant que
caster et amoureux des échecs c'est
toujours très triste de voir un des
joueurs à souffrir avec sa connexion
c'est toujours quelque chose qui me kim
qui me chiffonne quoi parce que battante
a envie de voir les mecs pouvoir
défendre leurs chances à fond et c'est
toujours dommage de les voir en
difficulté avec une connexion internet
qui laisse à désirer une prise à soient
prises neuf trois prises des 4 mois il
va s'accrocher mais vu que le match est
très serré que ça se joue à pas grand
chose ça ça peut valoir son pesant de
cacahuètes
wen et pau qui mangent en même temps en
temps je mets un peu les calmes
je n'avais pas depuis de thaler nebo qui
m'a l'air assez confiant ding garenne
qui m'a l'air ont alors après c'est
peut-être éclairage mal à battre un peu
rouge mais je pense que c'est la lumière
bonjour de position sur la question est
ce que les blancs sont ni ou pas à cette
fin si tu réussis à bien fixer des six a
placé des pièces en face du pion et à
l'attaqué tu vas être mieux clairement
parce que c'est un pion faible isolé
arriérés et les blancs n'ont pas de
faiblesse mais on voit bien que les
dents ont tout de suite fait des cinq
dons qu'ils cessent pas fixé sur cinq il
veut j'imagine mettre le cavalier e 4 il
y aura peut-être même des coûts
intermédiaires avec des fous bk des
trucs comme ça donc lâché 6 et
notre ami n'est peau qui propose nul des
cinq avaient égalisé et là nul est
acceptée accordés entre les deux joueurs
on va retourner côté blanc pour dingli
rennes et là maintenant il va falloir
arrêter les mauvaises blagues il va
falloir commencer à mettre des points
alors c'est une époque y réfléchit sur
des 4 il a peut-être pas aimer
l'ouverture de tout à l'heure ça mais
tant aimé se tourner la caméra qu'est ce
qu'il fout en fait vous voulez une
caméra automatique je passe qui fait
aller ça retourne dans la même que tout
à l'heure
sauf qu'il n'a pas joué des français 5
il a joué des cinq on avait vu une jolie
partie sur la chaîne c'était une partie
nakamura boc peut-être donc
il change is rock alors ses positions là
ça ressemble à quelques ouvertures les
mecs le savez vous ce genre de structure
ou pas alors qu'il mène une attaque sur
le droit système de l'undd benkova
système de long est très très loin ça
aucun rapport benko on s'approche on
reste loin et benoni voilà ça y est on
là à benoni et quoi vous pensez système
de londres système de londres déjà tu as
des quatre des cinq ont déjà eu leurs
heures de pur au centre comme ça là tu
as des cinq des six donc déjà c'est
impossible et mec donc les noirs là ce
que j'aime bien ce que fait notre amie
nepos et qu'il envoie toutes les pièces
sur le roi et l'idée de cinq là c'est
pas laisser le cavalier connectés angers
4 parce que ça aurait été un vrai
problème
donc il veut interdire la casse g4 aux
cavaliers en le chassant et 6 par an à
chacun que peut être il échangera mêmes
vêtements et se libérera un petit peu de
l'étreinte des noix réaliser des blancs
ça va être d'avancer au centre mais bon
une nouvelle fois j'ai l'impression que
ce n'est pas une position correcte peut
peut-être même juste retournant 17 s'en
prendre aux pions
s'il pleut on pousse on pourra toujours
éventuellement venir jouer la dame en e1
et ici les blancs prennent on pourra
revenir en f6 et reprend le pion en
douceur tout à l'heure donc cavalier des
700 déjà être une option possible et
c'est ce qu'il a je le prends tous âges
inquiets et puis on prend m6 et le
cavalier n'atterrisse et jamais sur la
carte g4
c'est un problème pour les blancs je
pense cette position j'aime pas le
placement de pièces il ya un fou en c1
n'ont développé la tour en 1 qui peut
pas intervenir au jeu la dame en est un
qui est sur une colonne qui va s'ouvrir
donc elle va se prendre une tour en face
le fou des cats qui est monstrueux
la dame h4 qui est quand même pas mal
placé le fou j'ai cannes en mai
clairement les noirs sont mieux après la
position reste difficile à maîtriser
mais les noirs sont mieux donc cavalier
e 4
bon j'imagine que surprise prise prise
son idée c'est fou j'ai cinq ans ferme
et la dame des 35 d'accord et champion
prend 1,5 pour affaires fou prend 1,5
éventuellement donc f5 f6
ils bloquent qu'il a un pion plus il
veut peut-être faire pions propre char
maintenant qu'il ya plus fous g5 qui
menacent cavaliers prend est prise en
main et éventuellement peut-être oui
même même carrément parce que si on fait
pions prend cavaliers prend dame eu un
oui encore qu'un voyage six échecs
cavaliers 7
on échangera un peu de matos mans lille
peut faire qui ont quand même 5 je pense
je vois pas pourquoi pas hein
andy est devenu mauvais dingjian quoi
ils jouent jamais trop joué sur internet
un ding comme on disait il à la
connexion un petit peu en mousse dans
les premières parties donc une époque et
un habitué du jeu sur internet pas
vraiment étonnant au roi a de suite
ouais peut-être éviter de se prendre des
échecs dans certaines variantes ont eu
cet ouvrage 6-1 parce que c'était des
cases d'échecs avec lecavalier et il se
prépare peut-être détour g8 pour jouer
sur cette colonne aussi suivant ce qui
se passe l'autre question c'est qu'avec
quelles sont les idées des blancs il ya
un pion moins pour le moment
comme juge et la position qui reste un
peu instable il va encore y avoir des
secousses mais pour le moment c'est
clairement c'est clairement le russe qui
al'avantage du pion et les blancs
semblent pas à pas avoir d'activité
à 6 mois c'est un peu un lycéen qui fut
d'avoir une collection fait brasser ça
dépend de l'endroit où tu viens surtout
que de la chine il faut se connecter aux
serveurs qui sont j'imagine plus plus
éloignées la chine a un très grand pays
à une beaucoup d'habitants c'est
peut-être plus difficile à gérer les
infrastructures sur des sites américains
ils ont probablement de meilleures
connexions sur les sites chinois
donc tu vas prendre compte prendre pour
ces huit voilà donc ça tout ça c'est
très logique et le roi qui pourra
revenir angers7
en cas de besoin pour protéger le pion
est la partie qui semble bien engagée
côté chinois qui arrive cet la tour
peut-être ans et 2,7 sur g5 yves leroy
eu six tours f1 et puis on prend y aura
pas de clouage parce que lecavalier
contrôle là encore c'est bien joué de la
part de yann qui est très précis comme
toujours
peut-être qu'à rallier g5 échec du coup
pour embrouiller 3g ici ce qui aura lieu
le 6 mai tour huit cavaliers ses sept
allaient peut-être kg 5 qui avait lieu
aussi s'embrouille tout cas ça prétend
brouillet
souqués g53 j'ai ici ce qui a valu aussi
sur gagne un thème pour cette tour f 7
mais bon h quatre là dessus et tu joues
quoi j'ai pour jouer pour h5 peut-être
pas fou fou mais ouais voilà il le fait
car et les g5 ça ça donne des choses
ouais c'est ce qui fait la 11e' et
peut-être f7 plus tôt mais toi c'est
peut-être même tour f1 pour jouer pour
du cahier g5 le retour ou fait tour à
lui qui veut jouer pour h ça qu'on
imagine ki67 la petite idée faire qui
est des cinq cavaliers ou sept qui
protégera la tour eiffel la qualité
assez bien joué ça et maintenant roissy
ce roi prend est allé pion qui avance
wayne on sait c'est un problème un ben
on y prend vite il est précis profonde
quand même
il est quand même assez précis dans ses
positions peu tactique après en longues
qui fait des erreurs de temps en temps
mais en bits c'est quand même un camp
quand il est en forme et quand il joue
bien c'est comme un métronome un tour
c'est qu'à tout pour mettre la tour
ronde des cats et bien joué ou même le
pion à eux quatre on va venir avec le
roi encaissé le pion des six
ouais et l5 idée c'est que sur e3
maintenant pour mettre la pression va
faire être quatre échecs wedding qui est
vraiment pris de vitesse et f4 pour
faire 4-3 mauvais début de match un pour
le joueur chinois
le 4 3 et froid trois pions passé lié et
ça fait déjà 3 0 attention là parce que
si on passe à plus 4 ce sera peut-être
un avantage alors j'ai pas envie de dire
décisif 1 parce que le match est long on
est on est après 30 minutes de jeu il ya
quatre il ya 3 heures 30
le match dure quatre heures en tout si
on compte les pose donc c'est quand même
un peu fort de café de dire que le match
est déjà plié mais bon c'est vrai que
quatre points d'écart ça commencerait à
faire lourd
ouais c'est ça en longue il peut perdre
le film en rapide comme il a l'habitude
de jouer vite en fait déjà en longues il
envoie et l'envoi et l'envoi et quand il
trouve son rythme il est difficile à
déloger
d'ailleurs qui est votre favori pour le
match de demain entre amv à l'eso il
analyse de cas l'ouverture gérer les
slaves
il en joue beaucoup pour vous elles
veulent favori réécouter ça va être très
chaud
6 août et 3 et maintenant il va faire
être cac imagine avec les blancs et
commencé à faire une expansion c'est
chose faite et préparer éventuellement
du f5 et y revient avec le carré y en
avait trois on peut même jouer pour dams
et 2g 4 f 5
alors ça ressemble à une française les
denrées perdu du temps pour réussir à
mettre le foin h7 donc ça c'est plutôt
positif
par contre côté négatif il ya g4 f5 qui
rentre comme papa dans maman
ouais
ça a l'air d'être une nouvelle fois
quand même en faveur des blancs là enfin
voir de dépôt le jeu est facile en plus
alors la dame qui vient l'idée sur f5 ça
a retravaillé province un gain qui vient
jouer le clouage rouach un jouet quasi
instantanément par un dépôt qui part de
ceux de ce mauvais endroit
à
malheureusement je pense que ce soit le
genre le plus précis avec reach ou 4e
moman bat il n'a pas été très bon au
grand chef tour à bucarest sosie racks
mais après c'est vrai que c'est en toi
tellement anecdotique
après je sais pas à quel point c'est
mauvais pour pour maxime de jouer ce
speech est faite aux six intermediary si
intéressant parce que sur dame prend
pions problème 5 ça refait une
fourchette
je sais pas quel point c'est une
mauvaise idée parce que d'un autre côté
ça lui permet de vite se remettre en
jambes mais sûr aussi c'est peut-être
alger
on savait qu'il a pris en premier et
donc les noirs qui envoie une pièce mais
là le fou bessin qui fait mal parce que
ça attaque ici ici ici c'est du trois en
un bon la position reste très compliquée
puisque le roi blanc va peut-être mal
genre fou prend 17 vous prend 17 da me
prends des cinq peut-être eu tout faux à
la diagonale et ça peut faire mal et la
colonne ouvert tissier j'imagine +1 dame
prend des cinq et un retour en leucate
sur fou au cices histoire de préparer du
fou ou trois peut-être pour gagner un
tempo sur la dame noire souriante c'est
un somnifère du pense que great shuxin
somnifère c'est peut-être le joueur le
plus le plus intéressant du circuit gris
juke ses cinq épouses 3 et bien jouer
propose les changes des dames et sur
dame prend b5 je pensais que voulait
faire dame prend 1,5
il y avait peut-être juste pas vu il ya
un effet emprise il y avait fait emprise
les mecs il a raté f1 emprise première
gaffe du match auj alpha emprise il a
raté la première gaffe du match pour les
peaux qui a complètement oublié la tour
f 1 ag senti quand les candidats mme
tremblay 5 qui arrive et il a été précis
l'a fait mal il a fini par gaffé alors
tu penses que lvl fait moins deux nuls
dans l'année que que great chioukh je
suis pas sûr
je suis pas sûr du tout qu'il est quand
même très beau joueur m triple champion
du monde de blitz aussi c'est quand même
ce cas d'un palmarès 1 dans youtube
c'est très beau joueur peut pas dire je
dirais car yakine pourquoi pas maigri
truc c'est magnifique et tout c'est
vraiment beau joueur
ouais ouais il ay la ilaha illa pas il
n'a pas été il y avait la pièce de plus
il n'a pas réussir à tenir la position
ça ubs boys en termes d'activité du bois
venant vrai peut-être mais double au
fait quand même tellement moins fort que
les autres
combien de sites et ses jambes massif à
le faire du vin elle et blanc veulent
quand même prétendre un petit avantage
grâce aux fous j'ai 2 qui joue quand
même pas mal sur les ailes dame et la
structure de pions peut être un peu
supérieure avec le pion à 5 qui bloque b
7 à 6 je vois futur top 10 nous ratons
david en panne n'aviez aucune chance
on n'a eu aucune chance de trouver
quatre échecs ce pas mal il dérange le
roi parce qu'on aurait plutôt aimé faire
petit rôle dans ce cas là pour sortir
les tours et là ça lui permet d'échanger
du matos est sûre vous prend je pense
qu'il va faire pousser si ces liquides
et amenez-le ronces et 7 et faire nul
c'est tout à fait l'idée donné peau
alors l'occurrence ici sera un pour l
mauvais on fera tour b53 c7 et c'est
être même les noirs qui qui au final
peuvent peuvent essayer d'obtenir plus
on s'en prenant un petit peu au pion à 5
enfin je suis loin d'être sûr mais je
suis loin d'être sûr mais bon peut-être
du tour b 5 qui arrive tourbe et 8 et on
joue un peu comme ce à quoi ça peut être
une une option
ici tour si ce don qui plein de dire le
pion maintenant je pense vraiment plutôt
les noirs un cube pour quelque chose
pour soi kf qui en qui parmi les jeunes
tu vois un futur très grand même tête
duda ci commence à être mieux préparés
fil rouge a évidemment artemiev le petit
niall sarine aussi je trouve assez un
terrain précieux dans le petit gupta qui
m'arrive a paru bons aussi il ya le
petit ça doit ni aussi il y en a pas mal
mais ils sont un peu petit mais dans
ceux qui sont déjà là haut niveau je
dirais white dude artemiev et 6 rouges à
doolow moi je trouve
autour des quatre propositions nul et
non en épaule il va pas faire nul ici il
ya quand même cette tour qui arrive en
bessin qu estion à 5 qui est un peu
fragile nom du bois que j'achète pas du
poids c'est c'est un genre de cfd geof
quoi pour ces 5
est ce que je vous disais un ce pion à 5
qui va prendre des 4 rc grasse et 7 mais
bon on va croire plutôt aimé tour ces
quatre peut-être vrai tour quatre tours
des 4 et si le roi par trop loin il
pourra attaquer les pions de ce côté là
et donc ça à faire nul
ouais artemiev c'est un genre de ameur
en plus fort je dirais je devais aller
ça fait nul
ouais c'est un genre de c'est un genre
de l'amr améliorer artemiev dans tous
les sens du terme d'ailleurs
ouais c'est ça c'est un c 1 amr à son
paroxysme année c'est vrai en plus ça
hammer plus alors il va refaire puis on
prend des quatre cavaliers à 5
non bonsoir transposer pense qu'on a eu
donc tout à l'heure ils avaient fait nul
assez vite il y avait un des cinq qui
était arrivé mais les blancs avait
toléré cavagnan un cahier qui
s'échangeait contre 1 foot case blanche
max et fans de tout âge mais battue sera
jamais champion du monde max après il
est très fort je le connais en vrai j'ai
mangé avec lui plusieurs fois
enfin comme c'était quelqu'un que je
connaissais pas mais
mais bon
je pense pas qu'il puisse me menacer le
top 10 mondial
en revanche ce sera peut-être un des
meilleurs théoriciens et peut-être le
meilleur seconde ans dans les années à
venir
double enfin
argovie moi je le connais un petit peu
tous quelqu'un que j'aime bien et que
j'apprécie je dois football wolf
j'ai dit tout bref n'ont bougé didouda
mangé du boeuf
j'ai dit on arrête je me suis trompé ils
ont aligné des noms tellement similaires
que c'est dur alors les états du golfe
non mais c'est dur parce qu'ils ont des
noms tellement proches quand en lisant
un l'autre peu importe
non je connais un peu doux après on sait
même plus ce que j'ai dis quoi bon du
coup quelqu'un de très sympa et tout
mais je le vois pas à menacer le top
mondial
duda peut-être si les mieux préparés en
fait tu aurais la préparation de double
au fait et le jeu de duda ce serait ça
fera un bon coup beau elle a du coup
vous préférez qui les mecs dans le tchat
après deux mois fabien fait prouvé que
ces manifs sur les ouvertures exactement
c'est pour ça que ce qui sera peut-être
le meilleur seconde en ou un des tous
meilleurs seconds ans dans le futur des
plans non moi je préfère les noirs parce
que je vois le fou ces deux et le pion
bloqué entre 4 et je me dis que le
cavalier va pouvoir venir s'amuser un
peu autour apprécié blanc il s'affaire
tour 3
f 4 5 qui seront mieux aussi dur à dire
mais à deux badges je croirai plus aux
chances des noirs de garder davantage
grâce aux cavaliers qui me semble
meilleur que le fou absolument personne
sur le chat youtube alors que ceux
annoncés - qui bug désolé mec soleil sur
le chat youtube
je vous ai peut-être raté j'ai un bug
sur un truc de double chat
j'espère que ça va revenir
donc ils menacent matin quand même et tu
vois j'aurais pensé que les blancs
étaient dans le mal et finalement il
menace là ils menacent la bon même si
français carême et six f4 après ça va
aller tu vois c'est marrant bon après je
pense que ça va quand même pour les
noirs 1 mais marrant comme vous voyez
les structures de pions comme on change
là c'est une structure de type benoni un
conte avait ici je fais souvent des
grandes mais c'est encore un structure
de type b donne une structure type
bettoni donc vous jouez une espagnole et
vous avez une structure de type benoni
c'est comme les gens qui me disent ouais
ok ça me sert à quoi de savoir jouer en
plus isolé j'en ai jamais oui on bâille
fait il se trouve que tu peux en avoir
de partout mais
fausse orangerie toutes les structures
d'options les mecs par ho5 là c'est très
intéressant puisque sur pions prend il
veut faire des six c'est quoi le bail à
qui veut faire nul malgré tout ils
pensent que le cavalier trop fort ton d
un tour b 5 prises prise tour à 6 nuls
une structure de piombino ni bon je
repars du début comme la partie basse
c'est ça être sûr benoni donc là tu
avais la même sans les pions b et
avaient eux qui s'étaient échangés et
avaient eux qui avaient été perdus pour
les noirs voilà ça c'est change et ça va
faire nul
j'avais une m5 tour des 4 way on va
faire nul donc ça va rester à plus deux
pour les peaux dean qui a bien réussi à
serrer les fesses mais il va falloir
faire un peu mieux que ça il profite du
pion g4 pour faire 4 il va prendre à 5
et ça fait 3 v 3 ça fait nul
ging qui a bien arrêté l'hémorragie qui
est qui réussit à stabiliser à deux
points allez il reste combien de temps
dans le dans la dans le 5 + 1 il lui
reste une grosse demi heure et il
faudrait qui recolle dans cette cadence
parce que je pense que le bullet va être
un problème
donc il faut qu'ils reviennent
graduellement déjà en 5 + 1 et qui
prennent l'avantagé 3 + 1 donc tandis
que la berri considéré comme ouvert semi
ouverte ou fermée aux gens c'est rien ça
lance à sa dépendent des types de benoni
mais je me pose ma fait je me regardais
à une position bison s'est ouvert se met
au vert vous fermez en fête ou semi
fermée d'ailleurs ça m'arrive pas de me
poser cette question alors cavaler à 3
pts et okalys et deux pour jouer t4
alors que le ventilateur de digne de
marche pas je suis en train de regarder
ça les pots qui a raison de bien
s'alimenter pendant les parties c'est un
conseil que je vous donne aussi de votre
côté quand vous jouez n'hésitez pas
quand vous avez faim c'est que c'est
déjà trop tard en fait si vous avez faim
et que vous allez vous alimentez c'est
que vous auriez dû vous alimentez plus
tôt et que vous êtes déjà en manque de
quelque chose et c'est un problème
d'ailleurs ça fait rire n'est pas parce
qu'il sait qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
s'alimentent trop tard et c'est
typiquement le cas le mec qui arrive en
zite note et qui se met à avoir faim bah
tu manges problème c'est qu'il faut
trente minutes pour que l'énergie arrive
bon bah pas de chance le line up c'est
fini tu as déjà perdu ta partie enfin
c'est dommage quoi donc
non il faut absolument s'alimenter
pendant les parties donc à plus fous de
cases blanches mais les noirs ont
peut-être du mal à attaquer alors après
ce qui va vouloir faire h5 pourra
l'attaquer je sais pas mais en tout cas
il a fait f3 il veut tout de suite
casser la structure et reprendre du
cavalier logique dam des trois alors
est-ce que cas les plans des blancs en
fait les plans des noirs la structure
marrante avec deux pions sans trop
content 0 mais f5 contrôle bien le 4
alors il va mettre ses tours au centre
des 500 dur à jouer quand même si on
voulait avoir ou quatre on serait les
rois du pétrole prend peut faire un truc
comme cavalier 5 peut-être pour attaquer
la la poser des questions quoi et
surprend pions prend bad as me prends
tout reprend et il pourra défendre le
pur 500 pas terrible cavaliers 3 et
menace une fois f5 donc on imagine g6
logique et peut-être il veut partir en
c4 avec lise est sûre qu'elle va les
prendre pour affaires pions prend et sur
cavaliers des cinq peut-être jaillir en
veut 5
c'est peut-être une idée c'est peut être
une idée
tours 8
on va voir maintenant comment ça va
évoluer mais le cac gagnant 5 prises
prise du pion là je pensais dame e66
d'ingrédients de travailler de jouer
mais on connaît dépôt henri joue vite un
même en partie longue il joue vite après
de temps en temps il fait des gaffes
mais comparé à la pression qui met à ses
adversaires il en fait peu et le
cavalier qui arrive en dessin ouais
enfin c'est peut-être bien pour les
noirs
après les blancs veulent sûrement faire
tout re 1 et 1,4 m sur b4 cette fois la
m rde cas j'aime bien les noirs en fait
ce qui n'était pas forcément le cas dès
le début c'est quand le grand prix de
tel-aviv sera le grand prix de jérusalem
du coup ils ont changé la place l'an
l'endroit le lieu et ce sera du 10 au 24
donc ça jouera du 11 au 23 en étant à
déchets qui met toujours les tats en
comptant un jour supplémentaire pour la
sagouine d'ouverture et cérémonie de
clôture donc fout carrément des quatre
qui empêche la dame de venir en quatre
et qui via un peu protégés afin qu'ils
gardent protection du pion mais jacques
qui reste un peu dans le secteur qui
empêche la me 4 en cas de prise en
prendre la tour on double dames bessin
qui veut toucher ici et elf ou qui
couvre aussi que trois évidemment d'un
bep cinq touches eux deux qui va être
protégé mais faut faire gaffe genre sur
dan b2 j'avais peur des variantes comme
ça vous faire attention avec un échec on
se dit j'attaque la dame n'y a pas de
soucis après se prendre un autre bon sur
la dame
il faut quand même être vigilant côté
dépôt khider férois f2 protège l'option
2 2 et protège la case de 3
peyrens dès qu'elle prend des quatre
aussi
kébé 4 à 4 d'amd 5
je suis en train d'essayer de comprendre
l'idée de québec a time termine en berne
tous vraiment viser un voudrait bien
installé sa dame sur une bonne case et
c'est chose faite à huy est maintenant
sur dame prend qu on prend il attaquera
le cavalier est attaqué le cavalier
samecki sous pression ça mais le fou qui
serait plus protégé donc c'est toute
l'idée la dame qui arrivent là et
maintenant est ce qui peut essayer non
ça sente pas fonctionné quoique il prend
une fois là et cavaliers des trois
cavaliers 5
voilà c'est ça sa santé qu'il y avait un
truc avec le placement de pièces et le
trouve et une époque y prend le pion aux
cinq finalement on sentait qu'il avait
pris le dessus dans cette partie et ça
fait un beau pions plus pour les peaux
et un avantage à la pendue alors est-ce
qu'il va accepter l'échangé d'une paire
de tours généralement quand vous êtes
mieux il faut le faire mais là le truc
c'est que les tours peuvent aussi
général générer de l'activité dont qui
laisse quand même les changes se
produire et il va pouvoir gagner cette
finale avec un python de plus
normalement
donc on va voir
c'est être un petit coup de hache 5 à 4
maintenant c'est chose faite autour des
3 h 4
là il peut peut-être juste faire passer
ça il peut être la tour c 4 juste faire
un statu quo idée c'était que surtout
reprend qui on prend ça à stériliser le
trois contes de mer est là il est coupé
le roi noir qui va monter vers 6.5 il
fait ses quatre avant maintenant la tour
qui bloque la 4e et qui attaquent le
pion il ya juste avant droit le roi
allait rentrer en c4 b3 b4 et ça allait
gagner tout seul n'est peau qui reprend
un matelas un peu plus confortable de
trois points d'écart ouais c'est vrai
qu'on sent quand même le joueur russe
qui est simplement plus fort que son
adversaire
je pense que c'est vraiment la chose
qu'on peut dire sur le match
pour le moment il le domine à la
régulière on a l'impression que dès
qu'il a pu un peu sur l'accélérateur y
gagne c'est parti là encore c'est une
partie qu'il a dominé de long en large
en travers
mais non classe il va jouer cette petite
finale et avec les blancs on peut
espérer un avantage parce que les pions
noirs sont très avancées et pas
forcément groupe et ce avec ce four b3
fait belle impression et les pions qui
pourrait se faire attaquer on peut même
parfois joué avec du à 5 tours à quatre
ou à cinq fois à 4 pouces et 600 prendre
un peu aux pions b parfois de cavale et
bien on sait qu'à télévision f3 pour
profiter de cette menace
il ya des cavaliers g5 qui peuvent
freiner et il ya toujours ces pions qui
sont un peu à la merci de l'adversaire
qui ajoute kg 4 eq réception doublé mais
sa règle pas le problème de ce mec là
alors sur un choix ya un truc qui
m'échappe et je tarnais puisque ça
m'échappe complètement accueille 6 qui
est le 5-fu e6 d'accord menacé fou prend
b3 et surtout grossistes 11.6 pour
mettre tout de suite la pression monte
aura d un fou aux six tours prend des
six prises des 6 tours d un s'il veut
troquer un peu 3 compte des six les
noirs auront une structure convenable
mais les blancs veulent jouer sur un
avantage de développement donc
donc donc donc
pour ces huit d'accord il veut tour des
six four b3 cb tour des aides tour c'est
marrant ça veut dire qu'il ya sûrement
fait rage trois cavaliers prend tout
reprend fou prend pions prend et après
avoir également davantage d'activités
mais ça va être là particulièrement
on verra
après trois tours prend des six ça ça
est fait
prise b3 prise b3 on va voir ça et
maintenant il va y avoir tout reprend à
6.5 qui menace sur m6 or à tourcoing à 6
on avancera le pion peut-être wave ii en
premier intermédiaire
car elle essaie de et on prend à 6
heures et non sa garde et dur pour les
noirs f3 à f2 salaires d'être dur ce que
tu dois bouger le cavalier état que ces
deux et tout reprend 1,6 et tu vas
devoir gérer le pion à après tu peux
encore faire cas malien est de battre
mais c'est une mauvaise tête
bader c'est la partie après ce qu'on
fait cavalier ou un pour couvrir ou on
l'est à tour arrive en c2 ça après c'est
toujours difficile de juger le roi
partir en g3 il va prendre b2 prendre b4
bon il n'ya que les blancs qui peuvent
être mieux mais peut-être que ça va
tenir pour les noirs ce que tourbe et
katia tourbe et 3 es sur ton franc qui
prend b3 il arrive juste à temps pour
stopper le pion tête du cou tour c4
jouer sur le cavalier loin et s'est créé
de jeu à l'e3 avoir à voir
qui est sûr qu alice et 5 à 5 cavaliers
4-3-3 cavalli ces cinq cavaliers des
deux cavaliers quatre cavaliers à 6 roi
des 3 ouais c'est show hyper dur à
évaluer parce que d'un côté il ya un
pion plus et les pions qui partent au
sens de l'autre côté y avions pas
s'éloigner
ça doit aller pour les noirs quand même
parce que ce cavalier tu peux pas
vraiment le chasser je soupçonne que ça
va pour les noirs il s'en est bien tiré
un men et pau qui a joué peut-être un
peu vite mais mais bon je suis le pion
bouger roi ckt il veut cavaliers 17 pays
ces cinq endroits c4 maintenant de 4 ha
oui bien sûr qu'ils les 17 cas ici ça
qu'on pourra prendre et envoyé le 3
c'est très bien joué de la part de ding
trois des quatre bien joué aussi
peut-être à faire cavalier h7 maintenant
3g six cavaliers fuite et sur walf cette
cavale et 17 3 e 6 ans vers la carélie
h7 projet six cavaliers fuite
bref sept cavaliers h7 peut pas faire
une nulle comme ça
on va voir
cavalli 17 cavaliers 5
cavalier c4 d'accord il veut revenir
avec son cavalier pour défendre les
pions à bas âge et cation prendre pions
prend 3 e 4 il va quand même sache trois
pions prend qu on prend au f 3 ar et ça
va tout liquidé je voulais vérifier que
les blancs et bien le temps d'aller mais
ça va cartonner d'ailleurs les leçons de
jazz comme l'as printing floch clottes
normalement je dois livrer la dernière
mercredi normalement je livre la
dernière leçon mercredi
mais normalement ça sortir en français
ce sera cool way sera bien des milliers
d'heures de travail ce truc mais ça va
enfin sortir se fait plaisir
ouais je prête ma voix enfin je donne ma
voir enfin je peux employer près chez
qu'on n'y prêtait la voix mais mais ça
va être cool je suis assez fier de ce
truc là d'ailleurs
enfin c'est un truc dont je suis très
fier je pense pas qu'il y ait quelque
chose d'équivalent français qui a été
fait par qui que ce soit parce que c'est
un travail monstre
c'est un travail monstre de faire ça
donc je suis assez fier d'avoir adore pu
faire en français c'est vraiment
vraiment vraiment bien c'est enfin pour
quelqu'un qui débute et tout c'est
vraiment quelque chose de bien j'ai
repris alors j'ai pris les 125 première
leçon y en a peut-être des nouvelles qui
ont été faites depuis
en tout cas les 125 première wii ware
qualitatif
après s'adresse à un public vraiment
débutants tout dépend votre niveau
ouais enfin un abonnement payant alors
je sais pas d'ailleurs lequel permet de
les voir en main mais on m'a dit je sais
pas si le peuble la bonne mort permet de
les voir ou pas après il y aura deux
abonnements diamant a gagné à la soirée
du 23 j ça je dis rien ouais c'est c'est
vraiment pour les joueurs entre entre
débutants jusqu'à 1500 venir
mais non c'est vraiment bien c'est cool
qu'on ait pu faire ça si tu les as en
anglais max tu roules tu les auras en
français si tu les as pas en anglais tu
les auras pas en français donc tu peux
aller jeter un oeil et puis tu nous
lâche tu ne lâches info -
mais après pour un débutant comme moi
c'est par un peu con de payer un
abonnement bas j'ai pas fait un mois à
chaque fois j'achète du contenu
maintenant j'ai pris l'habitude
d'acheter du contenu payant et des jeux
dès que je m'intéresse à un sujet
j'achète des livres hachette des trucs
bref aigles en huit ans d'âge
d'après vlad jusqu'à 2007 50 à peu près
un public assez débutants bon là c'est
un peu le même thème que la partie
précédente sauf que la position après
tout reprend aviez vraiment égal ouais
donc ils font nul avec des buts en lui
un louis blad arrêter de jouer parce
qu'il est trop nul
gagner oui je suis bien trop nul pour ce
jeu donkey là il a arrêté
il n'avait pas le niveau 1 amar en sueur
mais il a reperdu congrès tout cas
d'avoir enfin comme j'arrive ladhof
c'est un penalty quoi c'est un tour
cadeau tu lâches avant et le son en or
donc vous nombre est donc avec un
abonnement hors non franchement pour 25
euros par an c'est pas ça me paraît pas
très cher honnêtement à une petite nage
dorff 25 euros pas dans l'année pour
avoir accès aux leçons sa part et je
vais pas dire donner parce que ce serait
exagéré mais c'est le prix d'un livre
quoi ça fait partie des abonnements
assez bon marché quand même
c'est en tout cas un vrai travail
derrière et puis que t'as pas que ça t'a
les analyses de parti tu as tout un tas
de choses qui vont avec
on vient de leçons en tous tu prends que
les leçons mais t'as pas que les leçons
mais à 125 petite leçon après ces
petites leçons c'est petite leçon de 4 5
minutes en moyenne
il ya du texte il ya des exercices tu as
vingt minutes de contenu par pour une
leçon tu fais les 125 ça te prend 20
minutes x 3 ça fait une heure 120 / 3 ça
fait quarante ça fait quarante heures de
ta 40 heures de leçons après tendent à
être un peu à jeter à la poubelle mais
c'est les premières qui sont plus
courtes donc ça te fait kamin moyenne
atteint les a pas toutes ex avoir de
diamante huard est donc j'ai pas est ce
que les 125 rentrer dedans parce qu'il y
en a aussi d'autres de leçon
dur dur pour moi de vous dire exactement
combien pourquoi comme en mai mais ce
qui est sûr c'est que c'est vraiment un
bon outil et c'est pas la seule chose
que vous avez en ayant un abonnement
premium chaise comme vous avez tout un
tas d'autres choses et en plus vous
pouvez prendre un mois par exemple
essayer voir ce que vous avez 3 euros
c'est quand même assez assez sain donc à
lecavalier qui essayait de revenir vers
3 pour empêcher des 5 justement mais il
n'a pas eu le temps
j'aimerais abonnés grâce à toi bah ouais
mais bon ça me rapporte rien
malheureusement règlement du fric à
chaque fois une heure de leçon avec la
de vanille prenez convient je crois que
prend 250 euros vlad quand il a vraiment
quelqu'un de fort et peut-être pas pour
une heure ils font plus d'heures
d'entraînement dans nos ports nous
commenter avait complètement d'un autre
côté ont-ils le choix j'ai envie de dire
peuvent-ils trouver mieux
on ne sait pas celle avantage pour moi
de travailler avec les sociétés
américaines parce qu'ils regardent ça a
des avantages et des inconvénients
traque des américains mais l avantage
avec des américains c'est qu'ils
regardent vraiment à la performance ils
sont hyper pragmatique en fait qui
regarde juste les audiences et puis ça
marche ça marche ça marche pas ça ne
marche pas et ça c'est vraiment un truc
il ya du bon et du moins bon c'est que
des fois t'es un peu tu es vraiment
dépendant des chiffres mais l avantage
c'est qu'au moins ces des critères ces
débris critères ça c'est cool
mais je ne prenais pas spécialement la
bonne mort pour me faire plaisir enfin
prenez le si ça vous sert à vous donc
cavaliers des cartes est vrai qu'il ya
un vrai problème pour les peaux ses
pions ces deux noms qu'il devait
réfléchir à food et 5 ou pas donc il a
échangé la récupérer à 6 mai tour c'est
donc c'est vrai qu'il ya un problème
c'est que la tourelle et sur la deuxième
elle s'en prend à deux pions et très
rapidement le fou avoir peut-être venir
ans et 5 me rappeler du tour d2 pour
colmater genre tu peux peut-être faire
juste tour b13 f1 tour d2 et après petit
à petit tu il a fait tourner un web bien
joué tour c'est encore plus fort tombé
deux tours s'est vite
du coup il ya eu g5 pour couper la
connexion tour ces deux courses et de
hkd ghb 4 avait en fait peut-être pour
ça c'était pourri à oui mais si tu
faisais pas tous et avg 5 quand même il
y avait ce problème de g5 qui rôdait a
parlé avec le chat et aux intenses on ne
s'en sort plus donc
m hejduk a été séparée de ses parts elle
n'avait plus assez d'argent mais
complètement c'est vrai en plus
tepa pas trop pauvre great look très bon
est ce que tu veux c'est pas mal joué en
fait son truc année pourrie la fille si
l'élection mais il joue port tour 17 le
contre eux je file à darwin et great
schouppe est complètement y la seconde
et sa femme car il faut vraiment qu'on
se fasse le t-shirt mais il veut pas le
faire il est plus autres vannes il a
peur quoi mais j'ai dit faut vraiment
qu'on fasse le christ le le tee shirt
gris tout bougeait secondes et affamé
mais je n'ai pas une vie va peut-être
mal le prendre
belge suit empire balao prié le prend
mal et alors 7 6 ouais ça fait permettra
pas de casse pour le fou il peut pas fou
et 7 rbds et 7 vous des six tours b 6
pouces et c'est tombé cet état pas de
cadre est obligé de faire nul ils
français griche foyer comprend un peu
allegri tube qui a remporté à hambourg
est pas et en lui qu'il a remporté en
bourse fait longtemps après que vlad le
second depuis ce fait depuis a fait
depuis le début de l'année 1
ça fait depuis le début de l'année donc
voiture style anglaise symétrique et on
va rejouer une petite finale sera
probablement la dernière partie de la
cadence nîmes se réveille un petit peu
habile à trois points il reste encore à
distance entre guillemets signer peau
tilt un peu qu'ils offrent une ou deux
parties n'est pas dit qu'il est là pour
pour au moins revenir un peu dans le
match quoi il serait bien que ding à une
seule alors qu'à proposer nul
séné peau mais il est un peu moins bien
né pour un tas tout ça qui est
symétrique mais je pense la structure
des noirs est plus solide que la
structure des blancs avec le fouet 3 et
2 qui ont eu deux après il est plus
mobile au centre mais ça me paraît
difficile de pousser saluer ce gâchis
mais va supporter toujours rich aucoin
est maigrichon que ça c'est un copain
sacha ce soit un copain de l'adour ou
encore un goût un de mes copains c'est
un ami c'est différent nerfs ça se peut
que il soit réengager plein la vue que
great choc aura une belle rentrée
d'argent avec les candidats c'est
possible qui se repaît le luxe d'avoir
l'admet après off le mérite t-il
b 3 couvre son pion à 2 et joue encore
qu'on est là et j'y crois pas ou n'at
elle est belle je pense pas qu'ils
puissent il est plus assez fort qu'avant
que aussi fort qu'avant il est plus
aussi fort qu'avant après si ça tourne
bien et tout ça peut arriver mais je
pense qu'il est plus tendre il est plus
tendre il fait des erreurs et gaffe
c'est plus le gritche look de 2015 je
pense 2014-2015 n'en sera qu'à roi la
holding mais bon après c'est un tournoi
long difficile avec beaucoup de bons
joueurs
tout peut arriver
voilà le truc c'est que la paire de fout
des blancs bas elle peut pas trop j'ai
tata gamme les noirs qui ont un fou
aussi donc je vais d éclipser plus
cavalier contrefous après les noirs ont
pas mal d'activités après battons tous
fous contours cave à l'escem plutôt tour
fou qui domine mais là ça doit ça doit
se tenir pour les noirs après dépôt a
fait une belle bien jouer quelques coups
escaro rien nous serons candidats n'ont
aucun des deux des quatre à six des six
tours 17,3 fourcade vont tout ça ça va
c'est vrai comment progresser ici avec
les blancs fou quillan ckt quand même
malgré sa tête 3 2 3 ben ouais pour
couvrir la colonne les noirs pour un peu
toutes les cases mais c'est peut-être
plus tôt les blancs qui quand même la
paire de fou mais moyens tellement peu
de pièces sur l'échiquier restriction
des cavaliers aux cinq ports des fous
ces sept pour fouet 4faire toujours
toujours être méfiant on met à pousser
cette cavale et f3 ou cavani t3 est
nommé kevin froid et il va sûrement
faire roi f1 tout cas sera la dernière
partie de la cadence ça c'est sûr
mais peut-être un piège maroobé 8
annonce ici avoue qu'il recule là bas
encore du rhin
en 2010 n'est pas un truc incohérent au
candidat en 2001 ça fera pas très
sérieux
pourquoi sa cause de huang dao moi
j'aime bien qu'ils aient ou en gallo
ça change un peu mon là il vous prend
aux cinq nuls évidemment il n'y a rien à
faire passer de matériel donc à la pause
on tourne à la fois l'ami premier
premier tiers-temps cet ennemi quatre
ennemis pour les peaux qui a plutôt
contrôlé le match après 1 il a pris le
lead et b on sent qu'il veut juste
contrôler davantage et se dirigeait tout
doucement vers vers le 1 + 1 où il sera
l'écrasant favori donc on voit une
stratégie de match qui a été mise en
place prise davantage bon ça c'était par
la stratégie mais c'est ce qu'ils
cherchaient et maintenant on joue des
positions tranquille on fait tourner la
montre donc assez intéressant les peaux
qui joue tout en contrôle nous on va
faire une petite pause et on va se
retrouver d'ici six petites minutes
après la pub donc regarder la pub ça
fait toujours plaisir ça permet de
soutenir la chaîne et nous on se
retrouve on se retrouve derrière si vous
êtes nouveau n'hésitez pas aussi
admettre un petit polo a tout de suite
les mecs après la pause
[Musique]
mais
on
[Musique]
your fabrice picard
et du coup ça y est les mecs on va
reprendre on va reprendre le match donc
avantage pour yann nepomniachi trois
points d'avancé sur le joueur chinois
ding irène qui me
semble vraiment maintenant dans le dur
quand même parce que le match semble
complètement contrôlé par marianne
nepomniachi le premier tiers-temps a
vraiment tourné à l'avantagé du russe
qui a rapidement pris un avantage de
plus 3 et qui après a semblé être en
gestion et on va voir s'il va y avoir
d'une congestion ou s'il va rester en
gestion du coup et et s'il va pouvoir
remporter le match tranquillement c'est
vrai qu'on le sentait dès le début du
match
favori plus le plus la cadence accélérée
là il a déjà déjà pris trois points
d'avance en 5 + 1 il semble qu'en trois
plus un ding puisse encore tenir les
changes et peut-être même revenir on
sait jamais comment un match se passe en
revanche quand on va arriver
du côté d un plus un ça semble être un
avantage ce n'est pas donc il va falloir
rapidement revenir dans la partie pour
le joueur chinois du coup le stream
coupe il me semble pas n'hésitez pas à
me dire si vous avez des soucis donc à
4,9 voit peu à peu près ce même position
de l'espagnol prend tout à l'heure alors
une fois il a les noirs avaient réussi à
faire céder puis des 5
on va voir si c'est encore le cas
j'avais expliqué que le problème des
noirs c'était ce pion des six qui était
un peu arriérés et si on fait des
saintes
l'idée des blancs ça va être de jouer
eux s'inquiètent pour jouer pour un
joueur de quatre contre trois a des
droits
on va avoir un coût comme f4 aussi peut
être envisageable parfois pour jouer
pour f5 mais attention à cette diagonale
qui s'ouvrirait ils s'ouvriraient
dissous dans ce cas et qui vient f5 sur
fou prend on peut imaginer les deux
prises d'ailleurs mais j'aime bien ce
genre de position pour les blancs et
vous et ce n'est pas que les peaux prend
l'avantagé à la pendule il joue vite un
il joue vraiment vite mais pau et c'est
vraiment vraiment vraiment compliqué
pour pour ses adversaires de tenir le
rythme un peu quand même vlc
les deux ont un style quand même assez
similaire à ce niveau là en tout cas et
ils sont très très difficile à jouer
d'autant plus sur internet où ça va vite
même très vite cavaliers 17 ans il veut
peut-être jaillir verser 5 ouvert aux 5
le cas et qui vient en f1 il va viser la
case de 3 et peut-être la casse des 5 et
voilà ça y est il est parti pour dessein
ging
c'est bien joué sur qui on prend il peut
prendre à eux un peut-être intermédiaire
dévier la dame reprendre des 5
il fait encore un intermédiaire bravo
il va pouvoir prendre des cinq a laissé
bien seeding réussir à rester dans le
match
d'âme des uns alors surprise des saints
qui se passe quoi c'est exactement la
question je me posais je pensais que
j'allais jouer foot est roi pour viser à
6 en fait qui était une idée juste faire
cavalier g3 et c'est vrai qu'il peut
essayer de mettre une pression qu ait
quoique toujours difficile à juger est
ce que c'est le joueur qui al avantage d
espace qui est mieux ou est-ce que c'est
celui qui veut rentrer dans les trous
j'en ressens tu perd systématiquement
joueurs de position avec les blancs mais
c'est pas dire qu'ils sont pas qu'ils
sont moins bien les y visent un peu des
trois et peut-être fou ces cinq par la
suite pour aller s'en prendre un peu à
tout les toutes les faiblesses côté
blanc je préfère les blancs ici à les
noirs ici quand même
on verra
comment il va continuer fouet f4
peut-être qu'il y ait des trois il s'en
prend fou c'est cet ours et 8
tiens et le fond 3 plus tôt
c'est plutôt bien là ce qui vient de
faire une épaule à les derniers coups
d'échanger les dames du coup ça minimise
les problèmes des trous devant droit
maintenant ça va bien se passer alors h4
il veut jouer h5 probablement mais
peut-être pas dessus tête j'ai un truc
comme carey les d4 menace h5 genre la
cavale et des quatre essais ça protège
le fouet menace h5 enfermement et
peut-être même des fous des deux qui
peuvent rodez quelque part car elle
lisse et 5 j'imagine pour contre
attaquer ici quand même y avait
peut-être cavalier e 2 et cars a lieu
deux camps même ray et surtout prend
cavaliers prend bêtement et h5 et bien
jouer ce h5 maintenant comment ni pau va
réagir et thief & g h pour regagner un
tour et que ce soit de nouveau à lui
joué au foot et 2
il touche à rien pour l'instant et
peut-être cavaliers f5 maintenant
exactement pour menacer cavaliers cet
échec et surtout prend pions prend et il
aura les deux fous contre les deux
cavaliers ce qui peut être pénible ce
qui va tenter un coup deux à cinq
maintenant qu'il a un répit pour essayer
de jouer du tour à 4 et venir
éventuellement chasser mais y aurait à g
qui est pénible
vous êtes qui a valu aux trois du coup
protéger un peu le pion couple à tours
ça peut préparer pas mal de trucs
cavaillé g3 un peu dans le même esprit
finalement de bloquer la tour ivan le
pion mes mails à tout vendeur pourquoi
tour d un ce qui me fout des quatre
cavaliers prend et tours 17
c'est sûrement ça hein quoi d'autre
c'est fou ces trois si tu veux un truc
comme h cissé cavale et h5 un jour
intéressant en tout cas cette partie
vraiment passionnante
alors il prend maintenant ah oui parce
que tout à l'heure il y avait pu
comprendre le x y z protéger c'était ça
le problème
excusez moi les mecs il ya beaucoup de
choses à voir donc de temps en temps je
rate une petite et maintenant il fait
tour 17
et là maintenant il va prendre f7 et
cavaliers prendre 4 ou g6 échec et c'est
gagné et c'est gagné pour les peaux qui
prend plus 4 bat mais je crois que le le
scénario est écrit dans du papier de
verre là mon avis n'est peau qui est
trop solide trop solide
trop rapide trop fort + 4 ça me semble
être de plus en plus compliqué
d'imaginer le joueur chinois revenir
mais bon sera pas la première fois qu'on
était surprise mais je rappelle d'un
match great loong bouddha ou gris tout
semblait semblait dominer depuis 12 à
petit à petit est revenu il s'est
installé plus ou moins égalité il avait
il avait gagné au finish et c'est un
résultat auquel on ne s'attendait pas du
tout il avait battu d'ailleurs car
yakine un peu de la même manière mais
finalement il y avait eu deux surprises
comme ça qu'on n'avait pas vu venir
alors les noirs qui rendent le pion en
d3 mais c'est bel et bien pour fermer la
colonne des passes laisser prendre un
tour d un tour prend des cats qui serait
arrivé il met mal le pion en d3 ils vont
faire rock et il s'en prendra à ce pion
après il salua ali shah
je crois que leo n'a pas pu s'inscrire
que les histoires de geri lui a été
défavorable
ouais il ya une histoire avec avec line
of man de contrat qui aurait été signé
et guiry qu'il se serait désisté de
manière pas très conventionnel
après à savoir que
pour pour se qualifier alé lô et maxime
qui n'était pas vraiment faim pas au
courant je sais pas exactement qui a
suivi la règle ou qui ne l'a pas suivi
mais après tricks tu peux toujours aller
chez le médecin et te faire faire un
passé pas très légal non plus un mais ça
se fait dans beaucoup de de discipline
et la dame va partir en e2 alors qu'est
ce que ça veut dire
les nombres et les chiffres en dessous
en fait il ya trois cadence de jeu dans
le match il joue en 5 minutes plus d'une
seconde
trois minutes plus une seconde et une
hutte plus une seconde et donc les
chiffres sous les caméras c'est le
nombre de points qui ont été marqués
dans chacune des cadences le 5 + 1 c'est
ce qu'ils jouaient en premier et ça a
été gagné cet ennemi à quatre et demi
par le joueur à gauche des pommiers achi
et ensuite on aura le 3 + 1 donc là
c'est en ce moment en réalité et on voit
qu'il ya un point pour nepomniachi et 0
pour le monde pour 10000 irène parce
qu'il ya un point à 0 pour le joueur
russe qui la jouent à devoir quand même
faire face à la perte de fou dans une
position ouverte mais là encore un peu
d'activité les calices et 3 qui traite
ce genre de choses
ouais c'est fait guéri indélicats ont
puis si cela ramènerait mef
j'ai l'impression qu'on tombe sur une
génération de joueurs d'échecs qui se la
ramène un peu quand tu es twitter la dd
des meilleurs c'est un jeu pas forcément
le mieux placé pour en parler mais il ya
pas mal de manque de respect tu sais pas
si c'est du premier ou du second degré
alors
4 ces trois mais guéri je crois qu'il a
joué le speech est cette année justice
effet éliminé salut haggis ford
donc il essaie de tout supprimer de
l'échiquier dépôts et surtout bessin qui
va avoir un cavalier c3 bien dans le
tempo
ils sont à vendre pour la soirée alors
fais gaffe qui sortent parce que c'est
samedi du coup fait quand même très
attention se souvient vendredi aura
peut-être personne ce qui va réussir à
tous supprimés
cm elle va aux candidats c'est une
chance de gagner question difficile
il aura forcément une chance mais je
pense pas qu'il fasse partie des favoris
est mon favori pour le speech and mare
wesley so bizarrement
ouais non les histoires de sow était un
peu machin saleilles va la gagner 10
normalement il ya pions pas s'éloigner
tour fou après faut faire attention
quand même
ils préfèrent avoir un fou f3 mais ça
doit aller après né paul veut pas
cavaler sait si si d'abord poussé cette
j'aime pas trop la tour latéral j'aurais
préféré l'avoir derrière mais c'était
pas possible de le faire
ce sont certaines des favoris du stc est
possible et qui vient on sait caresser
bien jouer est tombé 5 maintenant
peut-être ce qui veut cavaliers pro b 6
ab et tour v2 un seul nul en maths on va
devoir aller ans et 6 et 3 et 5 ans et
j'ai cinq contre je bien défendu un à
part donné peut faire prise prise tour
ici hein mais tu menacera rien parce que
surtout reprend dur à tour ses cinq
tours b5 et on placera la tour derrière
juste pour montrer un sera un problème
si ce soir là
donc c'est pour ça qu'ils marquent un
temps d'arrêt il fait 3 500 m le rend à
f/5 parce que faire bref cateau f6 3g 4
aller bouffer h et essayer de sacrifier
la tour contre le pion et aller à dame
tour ses 4,3 g 3 tours b 4 tours c'est
un roi des cats ours et 8b cette tourbe
et 8 roy e 3f cinq ans et ça semble
aller un ce que roy roi ici f53 ici f4
et on prend bessette après les
retrouvailles peut même faire tour échec
et revenir on me farid 5
voyons ça va il va peut-être même la
gagne avec les noirs f5 f4 là il va
prendre prendre faire f3 f2 pour apprend
h4 il va revenir en g3 ils vont envoyer
les deux pions il va être un poil nigel
louis 3 3 il doit faire f1 et il roi va
revenir en f3 et il va y avoir un nul
mais bon beau sauvetage jaunes et pau ça
ça fait mal un pur pour ding c'est
encore une position qu'il a dominé c'est
encore une position qu'il a raté ça fait
mal ça fait vraiment mal ça
donc
dans l'en but
utopia leading l'irene sur les mêmes
bancs de l'espagnol un coup la joie h3
l'afrique et des deux ils varient le
score c'est toujours 5,4 en avance pour
les peaux et il reste quarante trois
minutes à jouer dans cette cadence
l'aventador fait qu'elle ait des deux
avancées que ça empêche que le cabinet
vient dans ces quatre et ils jouent h3
maintenant il a inversé les coûts ce qui
lui permet de garder le cavalier à la
bande
mais si les noirs ont le temps de faire
des cinq dans le bon tempo ça va aller
pour eux
donc ton c1
c'est dans l'un on verra si si car ou
gagne 1 mais moi j'y crois pas moi j'y
crois pas je pense pas qu'ils caroline
le speech à cette année pensez ce que
vous voulez pensez que c'est du troll
penser que c'est pas du troll moi je
vous dis ce type n'est pas un athlète il
gagnera pas le speech est cette année
c'est tout après peut-être j'ai tort 1
est ce normal que les peaux du fort que
lire anyway je pense qu'en blitz sur
internet ça m'étonne pas genre à nous
demander si ça va être comme ça qui
marche
ça peut être intéressant parfois ce
genre de variantes avec des pièces un
peu non protégé partout mais un coup
comme camaïeu 4 c'est pas si simple de
jouer menace dame prend des cinq
cavaliers m6 alors que 10 l'ordi dans
cette position précise en relief cinq
essais finiront par vaux kevin hill a
fait dam des trois qui prend le droit
dame prend 1,3 d'accord donc qui crée
quand même une menace et on prend ces
sites en france et si ces dames prend
1,7
on verra
on n'a rien n'est là - perpétrés mais
les arénas ça devient de plus en plus
fort les mecs
même pour un mec comme icare où ça
devient dur à gagner en fait alors il a
gagné en 960 mai mais ça devient
vraiment compliqué à gagner c'est
vraiment vraiment vraiment fort comme
tournoi c'est difficile d'une autre
manière que les speechs s or c'est moins
fort que les speechs s mais c'est
difficile parce que les appariements
fausse enchaîne les parties et à des tas
des castors ou des semis castor qui met
des points et c'est vraiment dur moi je
suis pas confiant à demain pour maxime
face à sow on encouragera font
évidemment mes sauts m'avaient tellement
impressionné l'année dernière il m'a
impressionné au championnat du monde 960
parfois ils se réveillent ils jouent
bien d'amd ci protège le cavaly c6 qui
était menacée mais après cavaliers ou
quatre mois parce qu'il va faire parce
que la dame est menacée ou là à temps
alors là il vient contre-attaqué ici et
ici d'entreprise afte 6 c'est logique
maintenant est ce qui fait prise à cette
prise c6 ou prises ces six direct et sur
dame preuve 5g quatre dames
j'ai ici avec avaler quelque part et ça
c'est juste une pièce de plus d'un match
trois cavaliers en l2 et tour g1 qui
arrive et là dessus pas tour g1 parce
qu'ils adam pranger un mesdames prend f6
paraît correct à moins que je rate
quelque chose et abandon direct mais pau
qui prend le large a quand même un +5
pas là il prend le large
la cayrie clairement il prend le il
prend ludwig
une époque qui a pris ludovic de large
la série que ça fait mal zynga dépôts
qui se barre et ding qui subit en
finalement il subit les foudres l'as
foudras el fuego baie d'halong adorait
rousseau
byron ritchie gré permettez pas mal
cette blague
y a pas de pause l'om est peut-être la
nature appelle les ports 1 quand je
conduis la nature et être juste à l'eau
chaude
appelons un chat un chat peut être qu'il
aurait fallu qu'ils se mettent le chat
qui fait comme ça ding ça aurait été
peut-être ça lui aurait peut-être porté
chance
je pense qu'il manque le chat quoi tu es
si on fait tout ça devant l'écran il
gagne la prochaine
on fait tous deux chats on s'est un peu
relou à force mais je pense qu'il aurait
dû mettre le chat pas loin
un dépôt qui se bat avant
il a fait un grand roque allez ça va
rejouer la taca fonds faut que cette
fois digne réussissent à faire payer à
son adversaire
qui a fait charest non mais on fait tous
le chat je pense un jeu comme si tu
avais les baies 5 et un coup ici idées
sur d'apprendre prendre ces sept prendre
des 8 et attaque là et là je m lors du
ce que juste et payet dwyer a un truc à
y avait cinq ces cinq peut-être bon il
ya eu 8 et 3 du coût pour donner le pion
et la sémec doubler ici
ces six pour blinder contre le fou pour
une nouvelle fois complexes fois h3
ce qui peut mettre le x h un fait des
quatre parce que tu es content avec les
blancs dehors ça il va t changeant ses 5
et là y avait peut-être cavaliers b4 qui
était trois qu'il a raté il commence à
faire des petites erreurs
c'est même moi je les ai vus après
peut-être quelque chose mais paraissait
quand même assez triviale cependant les
noirs son nouveau bien dans l'année pau
a vraiment il a vraiment fait l'écart
il a vraiment fait l'écart
la ville est hanté par cavalier f4 ici
il va commencer arrêt des cavaliers f4
qui on prend dame j'ai quatre échecs
connaissant le bonhomme pour aller
complètement enfermé droit d'attendre de
calculer ce genre de choses déjà le
joueur au drapeau tricolore
wen époque et qui rigole il est facile
hein allez il a fait cavalier 4i calcul
comme un fou dame g4 sayah roi est enfin
prise prise tour et 8,3 ici 20 et à
justin perpète déjà à minima avec dame d
un roi ici dame gk3 ici d'am-dam h4 est
déjà le père pète qui peut prendre et ce
qui va laisser tout est masquée à faire
un peu comme n'a qu'à laisser tomber la
1000 à la pendule n'ont même pas il joue
plus on prend il va pas pour le père
pète il fait le beau jeu écoutez c'est
tout à son honneur de toute façon le
permettent il va pas s'envoler même sur
un coup comme d'hab détroit je sais pas
pour couvrir des trucs de toute façon la
cage et 3 et est occupée par le pion
donc dépôts et tranquille
de toute façon prend là nul à tout
moment alors maintenant peut-être plus
ce que dame échec 3g deux dames et
cheikh rage 2 dont il fait dame f3 qui
est très logique tour h 2 il ya de
nouveau un père pète parce que le roi
peut pas l'en h à cause de toi en maths
mais je pense pas qu'il puisse faire
tour à cause de dames g8 échecs passés 7
et dames des mythes matt est le joueur
russe et sur f3 roigé wah wah ch
j'ai un voyage éducatif nuls année peau
il n'a pas trouvé mieux mais c'est un
bon résultat pour lui toute façon il
reste à +5 et il reste maintenant plus
de 33 minutes dans le match dans le 3e
plus sain et en bullet il va dominer
allègrement non qu'il est il est
vraiment tranquille un nom mais guérit
qui a un style de jeu intéressant aussi
il peut jouer de manière plus offensive
que vous ne le pensez et salua kauffer
78 et la pression de chasse comme
c'était 15 presse pour les peaux et
honnêtement voyez pas joaillier pas
d'epo en tout cas perso aussi facile
hein
là quand même il domine de la tête et
des épaules et de la queue de cheval et
appuie la pelure marque son petit truc
oui là encore on voit pas trop ce qui
peut faire caler ses quatre pour
cavaliers 3 histoire d'aller se prendre
la case je vais essayer de le faire via
cavaliers via poussé quatre pour
échanger ramène cavagnan 1,3 après une
prise éventuelle
c'est bien ce qui fait médine qui
évidemment va pas prendre une époque il
réussit à installer le cavalier en d5
alors est-ce que le fou à les ranger 5
pour s'en prendre à lui et contre la
casse de trois peut-être qui
épaississent donc il s'en prend là et là
il veut vraiment provoquer les choses
c'était vraiment su cavaliers cette dame
on va provoquer ici de carélie recul on
pourra apprendre on forcera une prise du
pion qui est forcément à notre avantage
avec les noirs et sur dame de on pourra
prendre ces quatre et prendre des sacs
donc il ya des échanges massif et là la
position qui va petit à petit ça plane
ir cavale et 17
car il ya eu six cd 5 par exemple pour
être un plan pour les noirs avec ses 4
mais là c'est un peu à double tranchant
puisque d'un côté tu empêches vraiment
des sacs mais de l'autre côté tu donnes
la casse des 4 donc on va voir comment
faire ça continue pour l époque et une
coiffure de samouraï et donc tourbe et 8
il se place pour jouer pour b 6 pourquoi
pas donc ils échangent sur manqué et c5
maintenant ding qui a bien réussi là
dans cette partie il faudrait qu'ils
gagnent un petit peu un pour être un peu
de suspense dans ce match qu'il en a
plus beaucoup
une époque il fait un peu la gueule
je suis tranquille damas il veut s'en
prendre un peu à lui dans certaines
variantes
bon ça joue bien des deux côtés un
d'ailleurs ça joue plutôt bien des deux
côtés dame g6 qui s'en prend à ça et sur
f3 il veut peut-être rentrer par g53
possible
il ya aussi qu'elle prend b3 qui plus
rodé avec des tours v2 par la suite tu
veux pas trop toucher aux pions f ici je
peux pas tout vrir la deuxième rangée
salut strickling found peut-être toi
alors un tel stress d'autres
ça a l'air assez mauvais aussi qu'elle
prend prise prise est ici j'avais
calculé sur dame cran il y avait d'un
prend le 4 way
c'est pour ça qu'il a fait j'ai trois
pour avoir de quoi bouger droit on va
voir signer pour réussi à faire du c5
qui a créé à se créer un contre eux je
casse qu'il essaie de faire peut-être
avec des tableaux huit tours des huit
qui peuvent arriver pour attaquer le roi
par derrière ça peut être intéressant
on y va échanger il n'a pas le choix roi
g2c jouer tempo alors maintenant le pion
est menacée ce qui fait 3 m3 cette
mauvaise tête wife 3 serait super coups
lui ayant défendre par derrière mais il
laisse filer le pion ses nus bout
c'est peut-être pas si grave le roi noir
qui peut lui aussi se retrouve en grand
danger
c'est une dame qui pourrait venir en b 8
il fait hk toi il veut faire h5 dame b 8
et touré tour a fui de maths c'est pas
très discret mais ça peut être très
efficace
c'est vraiment bien joué de la part de
dépôt donc h5 lui même d'un v8
maintenant attention pas tout reprend
1,4 passe qui aurait mat
la dame qui revient à eux cinq
maintenant ils menacent d'un prend h55
il faut surtout pas prendre pour parliez
les pions dame eu cette c3 d'un rêve
cette dame f1 dam des trois rois ici et
sur damas charroi f4 et il n'y a pas de
maths et il n'y a pas de maths alors est
ce que dit il va être contraint et forcé
de prendre là nul ce serait quand même
dommage pour lui il est à -5 c'est une
partie qui dure il faut qu'il mette des
points et il réussit pas à les mettre
il est ce encore une nouvelle fois filer
une position avantageuse très bien
défendue par le joueur russe une
nouvelle fois et c'est pas un mystère
si c'est pas un mystère et bonne raison
pour laquelle il est devant dans ce
match et c'est aussi que dans ses
positions difficiles il réussi à
défendre et à prendre des demi point et
c'est bien ça fait vraiment la
différence à la longue
cinq points c'est beaucoup et peu à la
fois ces deux trois parties que tu gères
mieux et qui font que qu'elle tourne en
sa faveur mais après si elle tourne
aussi souvent en ta faveur c'est que tu
es juste plus fort donc il reste 26
minutes dans cette cadence et on passera
ensuite à la dernière cadence le 1 + 1
qui sera encore plus à l'avantagé du
joueur chinois du du joueur russe in du
coup
wen et pau qui est vraiment bon il
défend bien ils attaquent bien il est
bon partout et je vous rappelle que
demain ce sera le match de mvl maxime
vachier lagrave contre wesley so alors
qu'on est dans le jazz be winner qui
nous dit ça a l'air plus ou moins plié
et succès qui voit il est rouge digne on
dirait qu'il ya vraiment pas bien là je
crois qu'il est de cette couleur est
depuis tout à l'heure
ce doit être la lumière où il ya quelque
chose
donc c'est de nouveau une structure de
type
alors là c'est pas benoni
[Musique]
ouais c'est dans les icn il ya eu des
quant à elles trouveront des 5 et que tu
as fait ed et les blancs qui vont
essayer de de pousser à fond allèles
dame pour mettre à mal le joueur russe
qui lui va juste envoyer un comme d'hab
fidèle à son style fida la fidèle à sa
réputation le joueur russe qui joue
actifs
il salua partie mais ou sans le chat b4
logique
les blancs qui vont essayer d'envoyer la
mare étions ils font des trois îles blog
bien une époque qui va faire g5 g4 il va
laisser son adversaire avancer dit je
préfère les plans actuels et blanc donne
l'impression de voir davantage d'espacé
pièce bien placé avec l'adav recettes
pour éviter ces cinq tours 6 fr est dur
à défendre celle là mais il faudra que
que les pommettes recâbler barbelés
parce que ça fait pas mal de parties là
qu'il ait fait quelques parties qu'il
est moins bien
faudrait pas laisser revenir sans
adversaires à plus 3 + 2 parce qu'après
ça peut aussi changer la dynamique du
match et ça peut aussi être un tendre
blanc qui restent solides qui est des
galas petites tactiques ducloy jeu long
de la colonne pascale adams sept
cavaliers a fui qui couvre la case 6
puisque les plans voulait rentrer dessus
foued sein qui voue une nouvelle fois
sur une tactique champions prend écart
et y prend fourchette
il va vouloir faire cavalier au cices du
coup au prochain donc il continue à
progresser il a installé une pièce sur
la case de 6
c'est le fou et il a le mérite d'en
pêcher au noir de pouvoir mettre là leur
tour sur la case ses 8 ce qui est bien
entendu très intéressant et ben non
c'est 5 donc l'avancé continue côté
blanc
et il en a pris le cavalier d'accord
mais du coup il peut pas reprendre du
pied on pourra avoir des cinq tombes et
donc on est obligé de reprendre de la
tour ou de la dame et maintenant le pion
des il va se faire échanger dame prend
et on voit pas trop l avantage des
blancs finale ouais bon comme ça aussi
l'oreille quoique il arrive en recettes
en premier enfin il est clairement mieux
quand même avec les blancs et quand il
fait tout reprend bessède peut avoir des
idées de damas est aussi pour venir
réattaquer le pion à vii
il a commencé par h3 d'accord et c'est
une époque y emploie le plan qu'on avait
pour les blancs avec damas est cernée
peau qui l'emploie avec tour des deux
dames b2 mais c'est vrai que c'est
peut-être lui qui met son adversaire en
difficulté alors ils menacent pas mates
encore parce que surtout rejet de il y
aura roi f1 alors il est parti pour le
père pète mais j'aime tout cas pas de
père pète pascal adam qui couvrent
exactement 3 g 8 et maintenant alors y'a
pas de damas un rouage deux tours prend
g23 pranger de et tours d2 ça paraît
classique est jolie
il n'a pas vu je pense que ça marchait
c'était très fort c'est comme variante
mais ça doit aller je pense que son
adversaire l'a vu mais dans tous les cas
il ya d'ahmed sicile échange les dames
et d'une position qui était très
avantageuse pour dire l on passe à une
nouvelle victoire pour les peaux et ça
fait plus 6 ouais non c'est un c'est
infaisable pour 10 milliards m c'est
infaisable
on est sur deux parties avantage l'irene
résultats 1,5 sur deux pour les peaux et
reste plus que 19 y dans la cadence on
espérait un un petit retour de ding et
finalement on se retrouve avec une
envolée a donné pour qu'ils continuent à
mettre les points donc là ça me paraît
ça me parait plier un je pense que le
mot est lâché
je suis pas votre avis dans le chatt men
et pau semble simplement plus fort en
blitz et tous en tout cas en 2d il ya
rien à dire je vois pas dans quel monde
ils reviendraient au score
ça y est j'ai mal pour le chinois huawei
après ça va toujours être le même débat
avec ses speech est ce là par exemple ce
serait peut-être le moment d'arrêter le
match quoi à mon humble avis dépôt a
fait la différence il a montré qu'il
était plus fort il ya plus si ce bon at
on envie d'en voir plus bas après plus
on est de fous moyens dream est né paul
acquis et au départ- pranger 4 et h5 et
lui fait cavalier avec 5
alors c'est sympa parce que ce qu'il
veut sur pions france qui est des cinq
est touché la fourchette proche d'un
garage est prise et qui est des cinq
alors attend les peaux qui a envoyé une
pièce dans le désert mais qui joue que
sur foot pro f 5 à 47
mais ça semble quand même un peu chéro
ce peut-être un petit excès de confiance
le problème c'est que ce même sujet avec
g6 pour avoir le fou qui est interné il
sera toujours prendre au bon moment donc
ça paraît compliqué de mener la taca
bien il semble que les pôles à face un
cadeau ouais c'est vrai que j'avais
proposée alfredo championnat
de pouvoir arrêter les matchs ou de de
faire un autre comptage de points bas
recettes ce qui me semblait judicieux
mais ça n'a pas été retenu alors
attention après apprendre pape d'un
procès et sur f5 ici ah c'était ça tout
là toute la pointe sic sur f5 y'avait
dame pranger cinq échecs
voilà du coup les peaux qui peut quasi
abandonnée
ils menacent d ici ça va mais là il ya
quad moi y'a psion est enfin billets de
pièces pour la tour mais ça semble
vraiment désespérée pour les blancs
brive on peut la jouer le truc c'est
qu'il y en a tellement arnaquer
au rang des mecs comme andy ward et
shaqiri plus que tu le crois déchets qui
sont redevenues quand même assez
populaire avec l'arrivée d'internet
alors technique c'est stylé bah écoute
merci à toi est bienvenue tu peux tu
peux tu abonnés à la chaîne si tu le
souhaites pas folle la chaîne je me
perds toujours entre youtube et machins
et et twitch donc à 5 jouer prendre
l'histoire et yvon l'asfa c'est vraiment
qatar là pour pour les pauvres c'est
vraiment pièces de -20 tutu bouge pas il
n'y a pas une colonne ouverte ya rien
après il va peut-être s'en tirer parce
que quand même fort de café ne pas la
perdre celle là
ce serait quand même fort de café du
ferrage et 7 ces trois des quatre îles
pousser les changes
des dab
c'est quoi le dernier tour j'ai joué à
la dame fois que je jouais c'était par
équipe en nationale 1 adulte alors
surprise en ici peut-être qui veut dame
ses deux pions prend b2 dame prend b2
m'améliorer l'âme c3 dati veut dam des
trois pions prend les 3 2 mais bon il y
aurait b1 et dames c1 et dames ces deux
raids ans à venir de partout
il a fait autre chose à faire c'est ça
ça reste complètement gagnant l'époque
essaye de de créer un semblant de
résistance
il réussit quand même à se débattre des
ruchers à ce débat parce que ding yifan
à plus de 15 secondes
il est mal autant il peut avoir des
problèmes de connexion à tout moment et
en plus il a du mal à finir les parties
dameuse six dames cette touriste
6 ces jouets c'est vrai que c'est un peu
étonnant ce café ding mais ce qu'on
menace vraiment quelque chose il peut
déjà faire tout rejet système d 8f 5e ça
ne va pas trop prendre 5 c'est juste
énorme et ok mais c'est ridicule
non mais c'est ridicule c'est juste
ridicule
non mais il n'a aucune chance
il n'a aucune chance digne s'il est pas
capable de gagner cette position ultra
simple il n'a aucune chance mais
peut-être qu'il est plus dans le match
si la mélasse et morin impuissance et
les riches le plus rapide oui oui mais
bon là au lieu de fin en gros tu as
trois parties août est gagnant tu peux
faire deux ennemis sur trois et tu fais
un devis sur trois ouais là il a lâché
mais je pense qu'il a eu des soucis de
connexion aussi pour être aussi lent
donc tout mis bout à bout et salue ce
qu'ils co donc demain le match du joueur
français qui sera plus intéressant à
partir de 18 heures
maxime vachier lagrave contre os l'eso
ce sera bien vivant bien évidemment le
choc à suivre
il a quatre bars mais peut-être c'est un
autre problème
ou peut-être juste il en a marre et il
veut plus jouer où j'en sais rien partir
de 18 heures demain
mais paul a écoeuré mais il a bien joué
à un dépôt la dame h4 f6 tourage 6 vous
allez voir ça va rentrer à fond il reste
plus que 10 minutes dans la cadence
il ya déjà plus 7 on s'attendait pas à
un tel massacre en les amis on ne
s'attendait pas à un tel massacre
elle a dit me paraît assez mal encore
qu'un équivalent mis en rage 5 et
nakamura jouera contre duda je crois que
c'est le 4 décembre tout cas c'est beau
nez peau qui va qui va filer vers les
demies où il rencontrera le vainqueur du
match tout à la camera ou pas c'est une
nuit dude artemiev en finale en tout cas
cette année c'est plus serré que les
années précédentes 1 c'est beaucoup plus
difficile de savoir qui va l'emporter
j'aurais été
je pensais que que dépôts étaient
favoris du match mais je voyais bien
digne que pose un vrai problème aux
joueurs russes aujourd'hui avec le glas
a sonné pour ding bixi qui ignorent
complètement
donc
food et un key qui va peut-être partir
en h5 tôt tard un lieu 4 ça à tout
prendre le cas ça prend des six
bon désolé - ici pour les commentaires
j'ai un petit peu lâché quand même dans
l'intensité regimen j'ai vu pas mal de
choses quand même et je vais lire sur
pions prend il veut peut-être faire du
cavalier g4 qui a valu à trois mais non
je pense c'était pas mal
gt gt gt pas mal mais bon là après quand
le match commence à être plié comme ça
c'est dur
autant pour les joueurs que pour les
personnes qui commandent parce que tu te
dis bien qu'il va pas remonter quoi il
reste pas dix minutes de match mais une
heure tu vois donc c'est un peu
compliqué même si les parties amicales
sont intéressantes à regarder la même si
oui quand les joueurs jouent d'ailleurs
amical ce qu'aime marrant mais le truc
là c'est que ça fait un moment qu'on
regarde ces deux hommes s'effilocher et
on a quand même l'impression que
nespouls bas il simplement plus fort
bond tension ne pas faire tour f4
surtout avec 4 et un truc marrant il ya
tour en tour f1 est avec 8 qui joue sur
le cloud agf et dams et 5h 6 et y
revient
en tout cas bravo des points quoi qu'il
en soit c'est un match plus que bien
maîtrisé wen et pau est dur à jouer
après je pense que pour n'a qu'à ce sera
un bon demi finale un bon apparemment
pour les demies à mon avis il peut bien
le maîtriser
tour 5 il va rentrer dans la finale
d'apprendre à me prends tout re 2,7
mais cette finale on avis il est pas
tout à fait fini ce que tous rêvent
cette fois il va être obligé d'avoir le
pion moins vite oublié d'avoir le pion -
mais bon tour b 4 tours 5 gré avec les
noirs il va vouloir çà çà çà çà raymond
soit pas allé bien loin mais le truc
c'est que dingli rennes à plus de 15
secondes
mais rassurons f 4 h et 5 eelv après
mouiller à une laurence et 5
il va faire bk travail va être pénible
d'affaires tour des 5
c'est pas fait encore les tours d2 d3
j'imagine n'ont ils pas reprend le pion
ouais mais le problème c'est quand tu
vas faire ton g7 sûrs à b5 et ça va être
ou b si ça va être très pénible parce
que ça permet d'avoir un bouclier donc à
faire tour g1 et p3 est toute la
différence est que les blancs pas tomber
cet échec passer une énorme différence
mais ces gagnants b2 ici et c'est fini
mon retour j'ai eu six haussier et c'est
de nouveau gagner pour les peaux qui
passe à +8 well as et ça vient
le pion v6 est important le petit pion
doublé qui épie éviter les échecs alors
a même pas besoin de forcer le talent
bullet et ses rangs une la
correctionnelle 1 pour 10 milliards n
bass et une boucherie de niksic ignorait
complètement on s'attendait vraiment pas
à une telle différence faite par le
joueur russe hindi rennes qui comme le
numéro 3 mondial même si on allie
pouvait avoir un peu de mal sur internet
des petits soucis de connexion
on s'attendait pas à ce que à ce que ça
fasse si mal et les peaux qui fait 45
avant avant d'amener de h5 cette fois ci
c'est quand j'aurai pour des candidats
pour mv alors si il se qualifie ce sera
du 15 mars au 5 avril et salue un fan
kiev m leur truc certains ont fusé ouais
c et speechless championship sur
internet tournoi officiel
donc il a pris le cavalier est née
baumann qui se sert un verre d'une
boisson
il rejoue la même la même chose oui les
jambes sont qui a rien avancer pipototal
qu'est ce que dit leur dit non il dit
que ça
les choses qui m'étonnent parfois pour
une pièce et gave un peu beaucoup même
un truc c'est que c'est vrai qu'il
enferme le cavalier alors ça a plus du
tout là pour ding qui a rédigé quatre
n'a pas réussi à ressortir et il n'a pas
non c'est une catastrophe
c'est une catastrophe les amis qui a
déjà plu suite ça passait à à +9
peut-être ding kiné qui n'est pas au
niveau malheureusement ce soir il est
trop juste si on va malheureusement
avoir une séance de bull est très
anecdotique qui servira pas à grand
chose
avec un écart qui sera fait il est même
pas obligé de prendre tout de suite il
le fait ce bois un petit peu de thé
avant de le faire on a un petit décalage
les coûts arriveront avant les images et
maintenant il va y avoir du tour h4 le
pion qui va arriver à angers 6 tôt ou
tard le roi qui est très mal la dame qui
va arrive en h2
c'est une catastrophe une nouvelle fois
voyons bullet ça va être encore pire est
tombé de 7 encore pire
la dame qui arrive en l2 qu'avait lieu
deux pour faire cavalier des cats et
chasser c'est la catastrophe ada bon la
bonne nouvelle pour ding sait que ça va
être la dernière partie de la cadence et
j'imagine que plus tôt le match se finit
mieux ce sera pour lui même s'ils
restent impassibles à l'écran alors
est-ce que c'est dans le bon tempo tout
ça pour les peaux qui perd quand même la
qualité en d1 digne qui se bat comme il
peut un
et qui trouve même du jeu niveau qu'a
eus se planter quelque part on le voit à
l'écran il est il est mécontent il est
mécontent parce que son attaque n'a pas
fonctionné il se replace les peaux vers
nancy ces pièces à lui qui sont mal pour
le moment il couvre tous les cas ce
d'entrée avec ses pièces mais il
faudrait pas trop de ça bouge sous peine
de se faire prendre au risque qui peut
se replace en d3 avec la tour et s'est
trouvé un semblant de deux de stabilité
on va voir
donc les noirs qui essayent de déborder
sur l'ale peut-être un petit coup comme
dam des quatre dames ses cinq tours age
ii roi ces trois dames 1
il va voir montant des quatre dames eu
qu'à 3 c3 il n'y a pas de maths et
d'ahmed de roi des saints qui monte
alors est-ce que ding lire n va prendre
là nul mais sûrement il en a tellement
perdu avec peu de temps qui prend là nul
bon il veut il prend pas de risques de
façon à 8 points de moins il sait que le
match est plié il prend la petite nul au
moins il tourne à la pause avec un score
encore par l'envahît ton à la pause avec
un score pour ifs a géré par un score
encore de quoi que ce soit il tourne
avec un score de merde il tourne menés
14 à 6
l'humilie ada et en août mais il va bien
falloir revenir pour les gladiateurs
pour les pour la dernière demi heure de
jeu où l'objectif de ding sera de
limiter la casse et s'il pouvait perdre
6 3 dans le dans la dernière
dans la dernière ligne droite il serait
content mais j'ai peur pour lui qu'ils
puissent se prendre encore un score
sévère on voit qu'il a perdu 7-4 la
première le premier segment cette
deuxième et j'ai peur qu'ils puissent
reprendre un score aussi sévère de 7-2 8
en avoir même 9 0 il va falloir mettre
les barbelés pour pas que ça tourne à
l'humiliation côté côté chinois un petit
peu comme comme les saracens pour ceux
qui ont vu le match d'hier contre le
racing qui même très dominés ont quand
même récents peuvent rester solidaires
pour pas en prendre trop et il va
falloir côté dingli rennes rester dans
ce dans cette optique et tenir les amis
je vous laisse pour six minutes de pause
et on se retrouve tout de suite
merci à ben suite et n'oubliez pas
demain 18 heures le match m
[Musique]
plus
alors les mecs
du coup on est de retour on voit que
c'est la rsc la presse c'est là celle-là
c'est l'art scrs pour repérer ce qui en
sueur on a encore des petits tableaux on
s'en fiche de toute façon le match est
quasi plié on va un peu discuté avec le
chat joue avec la libye qui est là est
peut-être arrivé juste avant d'ailleurs
ouais j'suis d'accord avec les big c pas
plus amicale car grande chaise tooway
c'est un tournoi
ouais c'est le silence m
ouais c'est à peu près la même chose
quelque chose qui est wayne je peux
encore aix il m'a aidé cerveau car l'aca
compte au sol
ouais je sais pas à quel point
quel point c'est important au final les
lots rapide blitz là comme une
suprématie en blitz qui est qu'ils
jouent aussi le truc c'est que les
grandes chaînes tour talent championnat
du monde de blitz et rapide qui a plus
de valeur que le grand duché ce tour et
du coup pourquoi ça aurait moins de
valeur qu'un grand duché son jeu c'est
pas le format est quand même pas mal
après c'est vrai qu'il ya des problèmes
de connexion qui moi me désole un petit
peu mais au-delà de ça
[Musique]
la tunisie a toujours leurs étudiants
allemands check point com est bon de
grand duché souri à l'armement du grande
chaise tout rebond j'ai envie de dire
palmarès c'est la même chose quoi donc
je sais pas c'est un sain débat à voir
ce qui est sûr c'est que c'est une
compétition qui est plus agréable à
regarder que le grand duché ce tour ça
par contre c'est le cas à l'heure
actuelle c'est vrai qu'il ya moins de
matches on comprends plus ce qui se
passe c'est des adeptes donc c'est un
format coupe je trouve que c'est plus
sympa après il ya des choses à régler
mais j'en ai déjà parlé il ya notamment
le fait que
pour moi un match comme celui là là
maintenant devrait être arrêté c'est à
huit points d'écart digne se fait
éclater il ya déjà trois heures de match
on en a tous marre ouais c'est un c'est
aussi plus bio en termes de taxe carbone
b winner tout à fait
j'aimerais dire ça c'est le tournoi bio
de l'année ça devrait être le
championnat du monde bio ça devrait être
le championnat du monde bio et du coup
le coût est peut-être plus décent par
rapport à la halle au rayonnement que ça
offre aux sponsors
peut-être aussi c'est à steve wallace
aussi peut-être plus bio en termes de
coût et quelque part tant mieux
mais je pense que ça gagnerait à avoir
un format 7 vos lieux du format temps à
mon avis les serra pour les joueurs et
les spectateurs ça fonctionne pas
l'honneur oui mais bon c'est quand même
mieux que déplacer les gens et de toute
façon ils font des stream de partout bon
là il ya un problème de connexion bien
évidemment sur czech comme mais non mais
c'est quand même plus bio que pensent en
termes de bios quand même plus bio il ya
tout qui bug c'est quand même plus bio à
prévoir et que je mandate chasse comme
si l'on bat pour le projet de mettre des
serveurs vers un dépôt qui appuie à fond
sur f5 way façon le match est gagné
tu as même le serveur chess comme il dit
arrêter le match les mecs même le
serveur chasse comme en haut niveau de
dire y'en a marre on arrête le match
n'est pas sûr
jusqu'avant collaboration avec kiko
serait bon il pourrait y avoir une règle
exactement avec 15 points et 5 points
d'avancé où il pourrait y avoir des
règles comme ça tout auto kirby un
lifting accès les serveurs pendant la
pause
il semble un le chenapan des potiers
petite grimace
on ne sait pas ce type n'est pas en
athlètes et les peaux qui a perdu niveau
qui a perdu la partie
il est tombé 10 ou le point qui va à qui
va aux joueurs chinois allait aller
digne il faut continuer ad dos le
serveur et ça peut éventuellement
apporter la victoire des dépôts qui va
commencer à bégayer
est-ce que l'écart niveau est vraiment
important ou dingli rennes il est dans
un mauvais jour
je pense sur internet en blitz et où
c'est vraiment le format de dépôt qui
est aussi très bon à dota 2 donc je
pense qu'il ya un vrai écart de niveau
étant dans ce format là mais bon ding
qui semble avoir trouvé la parade il va
simplement bloqué le serveur et faire
tomber nespouls à toutes les parties
est-ce que je suis proche du précepteur
non je le connais un petit peu mais je
suis pas proche on s'écrit de temps en
temps mais n'ont pas proche mais il sera
là le 23 charles europe 1 très
intéressant comme garçons d'ailleurs il
monte à paris
bon j'en ressens est en panique
vainqueur pour la soirée du 23 ya les
liens sur toutes les vidéos youtube
tu vas tout trouvés sur twitter tu vas
trouver sur facebook tu vas trouver
tu vas trouver partout donc la partie
précédente a été annulée et le temps va
repartir
bon
je veille à partir et on va être annulée
donc et encore une demi-heure de
souffrance pour pour ding
malheureusement bella nash dorff
je crois qu'ils ont laissé le chrono
tournait quand même mais ils ont eu
franchement ce serait dans l'esprit de
laisser le chrono tourne et de pales
façon le match effet il ya pas besoin de
faire un peu ça au rugby aussi les mêmes
au foot j'imagine qu'on ya déjà 3 4 5 0
tu rajoutes pas forcément autant d'arrêt
dieu qu'ils aient besoin quoi hérault
rugby parfois ils n'arrêtent pas
toujours le temps pourrait encore 25 30
points d'écart déjà que le match ait
fait il laisse un peu tourné même qu'à
des changements et où l'arrêt du chrono
parfois ils sont pas aussi regardant que
que lorsque les matches sont serrés des
sept échecs l'intermédiaire qui fait mal
et une semaine par moscou comme quand il
faut maroc et n'en sait plus trop en
projet sefyu malheureusement pour le
moment c'est difficile organiser tout ça
malheureusement
il va se faire mater tout reprend le
cadre food est ici se faire lancer c'est
la cata c'est déjà quasi mort des dépôts
qui reprend sa marche en avant et ça
fait 8 points d'écart ça ça va faire un
point d'écart ça augmente ça augmente
salut qu'à penses tu que mv elle a des
chances de rejoindre le tour des
candidats avec les récentes désillusions
de hambourg oui mais je pense que ça va
être plus compliqué que le classement ne
le dit pas ce que mv elle a quand même
cette mauvaise habitude disons nous la
vérité de craquer dans les parties à
très fort enjeu est là il va y en avoir
beaucoup puisque dès le premier tour il
sera y sera en danger donc pas prêt il
ya beaucoup de choses à avoir le tirage
au sort par exemple tu peux très bien
jouer là la wild card israéliennes or je
sais pas qui elle va si elle va à
nabatiyeh google phone mais évidemment
c'est beaucoup plus facile de jouer un
joueur comme ça où un topalov topaloff
est ce qu'il le joue troisième je sais
pas où un embarras que tomber
directement sur mam et donc il va y
avoir aussi le tirage au sort qui va
jouer jusqu'à maintenant maxime qui a
été plutôt heureux au tirage après est
ce que là le grattage va passer on verra
mais toi tu prends un aronian un gearing
au premier tour c'est moins facile car
navarin topalov un oui quoi tu vois il
va ya voir ça déjà et puis après ce que
si les premiers touristes prend un mec
dur il peut se faire sortir direct et
les autres passaient après ce que les
autres vont tenir craquer nebo qui est
capable de tilter n'importe quand mam et
qui fait pas une grande année donc
favori mais à mon avis va se qualifier
comme je disais à mathieu cornette dans
la vidéo que l'on avait fait sur sur un
craquage d'un joueur concurrents il pas
sûr sur des victoires de sa part et le
tirage n'est pas enfants sur leur
création aux côtés liste massy mais il
ya que quatre quatre têtes de série
donc il reste douze mecs a tiré à côté
s'il se fait sortir direct laghman pour
ça j'allais aux candidats selon vous 20%
30% avec les autres aillent gagne 2
tours s'est pas fait quand même allé là
ding qui est peut-être en train de de
faire quelque chose avec les blancs
allez mon lit rennes à laymont irène il
va la gagner celle-là il ya trop de
menaces
bon après les joueurs qui sont forcément
un peu en dilettante
ouais il va gagner ce que champion prend
tout reprend qui on prend ses protégés
alors petit espagnol
[Musique]
on a eu beaucoup dans la première heure
de match des espagnols
on a eu longtemps dans cette position
avec qui on prend des camions trois des
quatre carrés à 5 pouces et 2 qui
haïssent et quatre pouces et un message
à mais vraiment tourné à l'avantagé du
chinois n'évoque a toujours réussi à
garder les pièces sur l'échiquier
et à finir par l'emporter
dans qui rejoue avec la phrase des cats
a essayé de faire passer la tour le
cavalier en f1 pour aller vers chez 3
puis vers la case f5 ya les pions qui
vont aller en h 4 h 5 positions très
correct encore une nouvelle fois pour
les peaux ça va aussi pour pour ding
mais on l'a vu très souvent réussira à
battre le pion au f4 à mettre en
difficulté son adversaire avec
lecavalier avec 5 aussi et donc voilà
l'impression que c'est un peu le même
scénario qui peut se reproduire savent
qu'ici ding qui a réussi à échanger
entre 5 et à mettre un cavalier
bloqueurs alors j'ai 5 à 6 h 4 j'ai
l'impression que ce n'est pas jouer un
peu on ouvre à échec maintenant ils
envoient en espérant que ça passe mais
c'est bien moins construits après c'est
du bullet mais je le sens - moins
appliquée donc ils envoient vite ses
pions il voit ce qui se passe
il va prendre
il a jusqu à fait là jusqu'à fin ruban
que j'étais encore regardé deux chattes
la walck à reprendre histoire des
candidatures était politique c'est la
russie qui fait son affaire pour placer
de cissé et ses joueurs en fait une wild
card par définition
et décidé par le sponsor donc elle n'est
pas politique la wild card
ça s'appelle wild card justement parce
que c'est une place qui n'est pas
méritée par nature même une wild-card ne
peut pas être mérité c'est une tâche
supplémentaire pour un mec qui ne
méritent pas d'y aller
donc après l'organisateur de la coupe du
monde de rugby va pas jouer la coupe du
monde de rugby
l'organisateur ou en réalisateur la
coupe du monde de foot va jouer la coupe
du monde de foot c'est aussi des wild
cards et c'est pas mérité par essence
même donc c'est juste qu'ils
investissent de l'argent ils veulent
qu'un joueur soit de leur pays soit
dedans mais c'est pas une question de
politique ou quoi c'est une question
c'est le privilège de l'organisateur
après la question c'est doit-il y avoir
une wild card ou pas ça c'est une autre
question
mais du fait qu'il y ait une wild card
il est tout à fait normal logique
qu'elle aille ici un joueur russe je
vois personne se plaindre au tour de
france que les wild cards d équipe pour
le tour de france soit en grande
majorité française ça choque personne
qui ont regardé le tour de france ça
vous choque pas quand la coupe du monde
de foot
ça vous choque pas quand il ya roland
garros ça vous choque jamais en fait
sauf là tout d'un coup à c'est les
méchants russes à je ne sais pas on
semble sympa pour les blancs cette
histoire là qu'est c6 aiap à tourcoing 8
que le foot défend
est ce que le pion ces six offres assez
de jeu peut-être quand même il est bien
placé surtout en bullet
d'un autre côté le roi noir est bien
protégé le roi blanc peut être un peu
fragile ouaip y attend une nouvelle fois
pour ding wen à ses filles le pion est
maîtrisé ça va jouer vite côté côté noir
et ça va gagner tranquillement ça va
faire un quatre contre trois avec si peu
de temps sur la pendule ça va être trop
dur à défendre
non mais la wild card il faut être
il faut être quand même une fois qu'un
mais lisible faut être quand même
éligibles c'est pas si simple
donc allez on va voir comment ça va se
conclure il défend quand même bien là
dingli rennes il reste combien de temps
à jouer
il reste seize minutes il ya toujours
huit points d'écart mais une époque il
réussit pas arnaquer ça et il est même
déconnecté n'est pas reconnecté ça
il a même pas senti vu qu'il n'avait pas
joué mais là son roi est coupée allez va
revenir en c4 tour des 5 3 des 4 je fais
trois prises prise ça à faire nul
il reste à plus 8
il reste à +8 et il reste 15 minutes 30
à jouer
c'est juste dommage waremme veulent
arriver en demi finales toutes les
compétitions internes allait échouer au
pied du mur et met à l'iccn qu arriver
sur un tapis rouge en racks et l'excès n
co pour la peine il n'était pas qualifié
pour les grands prix dont il n'a pas pu
jouer les grands prix il a fait un super
parcours en coupe du monde et il a été
éliminé par un mec fort je sais plus qui
a éliminé à l'excès n comme c'était soit
duding l'ired soit du 7 et du lourd donc
il a fait une grosse coupe du monde
il a fait premier non qualifié de la
head of men où elle est éliminée par à
dingila fait premier qualifié de la i
love semaine il finit devant magnus
carlsen donc quand même vous pouvez me
dire qu'ils méritent pas il a 22 ans il
a il a 7 ans de moins que maxime et il
est russe donc
je crois que ça va bien se passer un de
dire qu'à l'externe que la mérite pas je
vois pas quels arguments le mec fait
deux tournois qualificatifs il fait il
fait un quart éliminé par ding numéro 3
mondial qui venait de pâtre magnus en
rapide et il fait premier non qualifié
d' un truc où il finit devant carl scène
ça va bien se passer 1 et voilà un petit
poucet 5 en douceur donc avec ces hyènes
quo quand même c'est pas malin ce qui
fait il a aussi gagné le championnat
d'europe par équipes avec sa nation la
russie puisque il joua il joue il joue
avec son pays il défend les couleurs de
son pays ce qui est quand même tout à
son honneur donc
j'adorerais que maxime et la wild card
s'est pas là le problème mais j'en ai un
peu marre de cette annexe cn co by shing
où finalement ou finalement finalement
l'impression que ce mec-là ne mérite
rien quoi donc bien sûr maxime doit pas
compter sur la wild card il peut se
qualifier par lui-même il en a largement
le talent et le niveau et il va y
arriver
vous pouvez dire qu'il la mérite pas
d'accord il la mérite pas mais je suis
pas d'accord je vois pas pourquoi il a
mériterait il est éligible il est russe
donc gens pas pour elle a mérité - que
vous l'avez peut-être moins cne peau
mais de toute façon les russes ont dit
qu entre deux eaux ici organisera un
match là c'est un joli plus personne ne
mérite rien n'y a plus de cap pour rien
il ya plus de financement et et
voilà par contre quand il ya des wild
cards aux grandes chaînes tours paris et
qui a des joueurs français qui le joue
je vous entends pas dire aux grandes
chez sourds etienne bacrot mérite pas la
wild card
je vous ai pas entendu dire ça quand il
y avait une grande pièce sur paris il ya
un an ou deux avec et chrétienne à jouer
on était tous très heureux d'avoir et
tiennent bon prix les français donc là
automatiquement c'est plus normal mais
franchement je trouve que c'est c'est
pas sympa en verre en vers alex nkodia
qui la méritent pas kabyle the black up
l'alléluia les séries qu'on n'a pas eu
le temps de suivre ces derniers progrès
je suis d'accord avec toi écoute façon
comme je vous dis hein je vais repartir
sur mon premier et ce sera dernier
argument par définition une wild card
s'est pas au mérite vos mérites
s'appelle une qualification c'est tout
c'est tout point barre
il n'ya pas épiloguer plus que ça on
fait la même chose dans toutes les
disciplines quand ça se passe en france
on fera la même chose aux jo qui seront
en 2000 ces quelques années les jo 2022
2024 2024 sûrement faire exactement la
même chose je de paris aura tout un tas
de francs cette équipe française qui
participeront à un tas de sport où on ne
serait pas aller et on y sera parce que
s'est organisée à paris en france
il y aura une nouvelle fois personne qui
dirait que la france mérite pas d'y être
donc on va un peu se calmer avec à
l'iccn coherus tout le monde fait comme
ça tous les pays du monde font ça dans
toutes les compétitions de tous donc il
va falloir un petit peu arrêter quand
même avec
et avec alix enhco qui ma foi a quand
même eu le mérite d'aller jouer là il
hoffman pour tenter de se qualifier et
peut-être fou quand même cet échec
intermédiaires non tout cas partie et
nouvelle fois anecdotique un dépôt qui
jouent complètement à larache match est
gagné il fait la moue vous avez compris
que c'est le sujet le sujet pour
m'énerver ça c'est vous et vous êtes
forme non mais avouez quand même c'est
un peu agaçant quoi mais il est au même
niveau que n'est pas pour l'avoir tu as
fixe parce qu'il est éligible en fait
les rues justement ils veulent que les
deux faces un matches l'un contre
l'autre si les peaux n'est pas qualifié
justement pour que ce soit le plus
mérité possible et justement pour pas
que la wild card soit donnée parce
qu'intel a plus des lots qu'un autre
c'est juste pour faire un match pour qui
est vraiment un mec qui se qualifie
entre guillemets ccc en fait celle
inverse
en fait c'est l'inversé justement ils
font un match entre les deux pour que
justement ce celui qui la méritent
vraiment le plus et qui gagne ce match
qu'ils aillent donc c'est c'est vraiment
le la tour la tourelle pas très bien
bah c'est pas vraiment hypocrite the
beat mathys heures en face effet dans
cavaillon ou trois kilos à la tour elle
va elle va faire la gueule on avis
quoique battu son jeune époux est en
roue libre au total non vous n'êtes plus
à redire que vous des raisons ne plus
rien dire non plus vous savez je suis
sensible sur la question
non mais du coup be bop cmv est les plus
forts il se qualifiera point bas à un
point bas rhin non malick sène comme
héritant quand même les mecs avec cenco
méritant après maxime façon il déraille
se qualifiera et puis c'est tout il
reste quand même grand favori et voilà
et puis s'il se qualifie pas c'est
qu'ils n'avaient pas le niveau et puis
c'est toujours au bout d'un moment on a
tous très envie qu'il y soit moi le
premier mais plus ça m'arrange s'y plier
ça va s'arranger largement silva en plus
même des intérêts personnels pour qu'il
y aille mais mais bon car après c'est
comme ça s'il assure le dernier gp iqra
qui se fait qui se fait éliminer au
premier tour et que les autres passent à
sa place ou d'un moment c'est qu'il aura
moins mérité c'est tout et ça lui
faisait quinio qui va se coucher
ciao ciao à demain 18h pour le match du
mv a du goût
alors népoty va encore en perdre une
cette fois cette fin de match est
vraiment décousu réparties ont largement
baissé en intensité
donc
après aussi le scénario où il ya ma mais
qui se qualifie et est du coup la wild
card il rend vainqueur du match n'est
pas valenciennes qu il y aussi ce cas de
figure et on propose demain victoire de
maxime à l'arraché un point d'écart
non mais bien jouer les matches à fort
enjeu pour moi ça fait ça fait vraiment
partie
ça fait vraiment partie aussi du haut
niveau c'est juste cause échec on n'est
pas pendant parlé ce matin avec fap
d'ailleurs on n'est pas habitués au
format coupé a récompensé les vainqueurs
plus que les autres mais si au grand
prix en fête ont donné on faisait un peu
comme un système atp et qu'on donnait
plus de points pour celui qui gagne le
grand prix parce que là celui qui va en
finale marquent cinq points et celui qui
gagne marque 7 et du coup il ya peu de
différence en fait entre la première
place la deuxième et les demi finales
mais si on faisait comme un circuit atp
et qu'on donnait un grand chelem et
qu'on donnait 2000 au premier 1200 au
deuxième
en réalité maxime l'aï serait il serait
pas deuxièmes et quatrièmes avec un
petit retard sur les deux autres donc il
faut aussi souligner en faveur du
français pour pas toujours à être contre
les autres je suis obligé de me faire
l'avocat du diable parce que vous le
ferez jamais je le fais un petit peu
l'avocat du label mais le système de
comptage des points en grand prix est
largement favorable à maxime
alors après je suis le premier en est
content c'est tant mieux et enfin ça
nous arrange bien mais je veux dire par
là il faut pas toujours penser qu'il ya
complot contre nous là c'est aussi
quelque chose qui pour la peine tourne
plutôt bien en notre faveur
et c'est tant mieux c'est tant mieux
donc vous ces trois là faire tout
reprendre des cinq anneaux et bien sûr
biesmans heures c'est vrai ça nous
arrange et tant mieux mais je gère par
là que toutes les règles ne sont pas
faites contre contre maxime ou contre
nous il ya des règles qui sont parfois à
notre avantage et d'autres à notre
désavantage c'est comme ça
et c'est tant mieux
du coup sykes et règlements ça sent une
fois une fois certains faveur et notre
foi sans ta défaveur
il faut faire avec un toute façon ces
mêmes pour tout le monde
donc
donc donc après le fait que dirige soit
retiré tout rond à s'il n'avait pas le
droit ça c'est différent siguiri est
sorti de la règle y aurait dû avoir
sanction là c'est différent
mais après ce qu'il avait vraiment pas
le droit ou quoi je sais pas j'ai pas
vraiment lui les contrats en détail
en tout cas cette partie du canyon
points d'écart de points d'écart
finalement dix qui aura bien qui aura
bien serré serré je vois là sur salat il
n'est pas très bien avec les blancs
alors faire ça et elle prend ainsi ce
n'est pas qui réussit toujours pas à
mater digne qui se défend comme un beau
diable est dans le dur ding il est dans
le dur et ivas fermathe et j'imagine il
fait une énorme résistance 1 il a
peut-être raté d'ailleurs n'est pas
incroyable la défense de ding qui
défendent qui défend tout il va réussir
à rentrer en la finale incroyable qu'ils
se soient pas fait mater et salue cyril
il va peut-être tiré s'annulent allait
rester encore une partie où dos derrière
le temps qui s'égrène
non c'est aussi la marque des grands
champions un ding
c'est richard virenque champion de
rester comme ça dans le match et de et
tout donner même contre un adversaire
plus fort là dans la cadence
il va réussir à prendre là nul a laissé
bien jouer y résister il va en rester
probablement une seule partie si le
chrono est bon genre qui sont
paris-match encore prise je crois
vraiment que les deux en ont marre mais
bon c'est plus difficile entre
guillemets de rester dedans pour pour le
chinois ayant ayant perdu le match et
c'est quand même beau ce qu'il fait
n'est pas après six rencontres et n'a
qu'à au prochain tour
j'ai peur pour lui 6 6 déconcentre trop
ici laisse des points contre maca faudra
vraiment qu'ils réalisent le match
parfait
enfin vraiment réalisé un match plein
sans sautes de concentration pour
réussir à se débarrasser de l'américain
s'il se qualifie bien entendu
donc le cavalier noir qui va arriver à
f5
c'est pour ça qu'il a pris angers 4 et
qui part avec le roi de l'autre côté
pour les noirs une qualité plus c'est
une position gagnante mais c'est du
bullet faut-il encore réaliser la
victoire
je rappelle qu'à 21h on aura un autre
stream sur ma chaîne perso que vous
pourrez suivre en direct le lien juste
en dessous vous pourrez contrôler contre
les gens mais j'ai pas ce que ça va
donner j'ai toujours peur là quand je
fais beaucoup de commentaires voir si je
joue bien ou pas vers amiens on écoute
un match 5 adam f 5 échecs qui est
français 4 ouais c'est bien joué parce
que il protégé d'un côté et fois justice
qu'elle prend vous prend et c'est gagné
et je crois que c'était la dernière à
moins que il ya eu un problème avec le
chrono non voilà c'était la dernière et
ding qui va finir à moins 7 et qui va
pas perdre la section bull est donc
bravo à bravo adding nom qui va même
gagné la section du lait de 5 à 4 saha
lui mettra un peu de baume au coeur de
finir sur une bonne note comme ça et
donc il n'aura pas perdu les trois
sections
il sera revenu au courage sur son
adversaire
donc moi ce que je vous propose c'est je
vous met une petite pub et je vais faire
leur aide rapidement comme ça vous
n'allez pas vous la taper longtemps et
on va et on va se retrouver sur les
coups de 21h sur ma chaîne en espérant
qu'on puisse faire quelque chose de
sympa n'est pas voir ses jardins oui
mais bon fallait quand même côté dinger
rester concentré et donc c'est bien
qu'il ait gardé la qu'il ait gagné la
manche ou ne pas faire un raid sur czech
com
vous mettre la petite pub mais je vais
pas la laisser comme ça ça fera leur ai
dit vous n'allez pas vous la tap et
toulon et on se retrouvera demain à 18
heures pour pour le choc mvl qui aura un
match très difficile contre os les sauts
légèrement favori mais il faudra il
faudra faire le boulot si vous êtes
nouveau
n'hésitez pas à flots la chaîne et je
vous dis à tout à l'heure
ciao ciao